Auf der Hand schon?
Genau, alle erwarten, dass wir uns heute wieder hoffnungslos streiten, ist ja das klar.
Ja, ich weiß und ich bin verkatert, das ist nicht gut. Ich bin vielleicht total aggressiv.
Ich bin total entspannt.
Ich kann ja leider nicht vorab, weißte mal, Kopfhörer aufpassen.
Ja, und wir begrüßen alle Hörer. Das ist auch mal ganz gut, weil das machen wir selten genug. Aber das halte ich für sehr angemessen. Alle Hörer zu begrüßen.
Achso, alle drei?
Genau, wir begrüßen alle drei Hörer. Mal schauen, wie viele sich jetzt hier schon zugeklinkt haben. Aber ich hab gerade einen Bug gefunden. In unserem tollen Scene im Streaming-Network. Die kommen nämlich nicht mit Unicode-Characters in der Beschreibung.
Was hast du jetzt reingeschrieben?
Ich hab schon mal einen Titel für die Sendung vorgegeben, ausnahmsweise.
Den muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Bist du den jetzt auch über 3G drin oder ganz lame über WLAN?
Jetzt bin ich ganz lame über den WLAN drin.
Max, wollen wir nämlich dazu sagen, hat heute den mit Abstand höchsten Leadness-Faktor. Ja, find ich schon. Zumindest hast du den unbestreitbar höchsten Fanboy-Faktor.
Ich wollte halt das Ding haben, wenn überhaupt eins.
Okay, also du hast das iPad 3G.
Genau.
Ich hab ein iPad WLAN und Dennis hat keins. So sieht es nämlich aus. Wir haben ja sozusagen für jede mögliche Konfiguration, die so der Mac-Nerd im Jahre 2010 im Anomai sozusagen haben kann, haben wir ja sozusagen einen passenden Stellvertretender.
Dennis hat nicht mal mehr sein iPhone, also seitdem er seine Kneipe verloren hat.
Der Witz ist jetzt durch. Der ist alt, ja. Achso, kannst du hier nochmal meinen Schlüpfer-Teil... runterziehen? Den Schlüpfer runterziehen? Wir müssen die akustischen Maßnahmen hier nochmal ein bisschen optimieren. Ich bin ja kurz davor, das hier auch wirklich zu perfektionieren, aber noch ist es nicht so weit. Aber wir wollen euch natürlich hier eine möglichst heilfreie...
So wird der Darkroom hier abgedunkelt.
Podcast-Empfangsexperience.
Sah vorher aber schöner aus.
So, hier unser iPad-Teaser.
Vor allem ist der vorhin so rot, dass man den Brutspritzer nicht so drauf sieht.
Wir haben Zuhörer.
Wir haben Zuhörer. Oh shit.
Also, mir nehmt euch Jungs. iPad, wir haben eins.
Zwei.
Ich sehe zwei hier.
Wir haben... Wir, ich und Max haben je eins. So war das gemeint. Du bist jetzt im Prinzip schon raus.
Also, die müssen erst mal...
Du blickst in so ein altes... Äh, so ein Steinzeit-Computer.
Das ist geil. Ich hab hier Multitasking.
Mit Löchern an der Seite.
Wie, zwei Programme gleichzeitig?
Wie bist du da drauf?
Und ich könnte flashen, wenn ich wollte.
Du könntest flashen.
Aber ich hab ja Click to Flash. Um es nochmal zu sagen, Click to Flash ist einfach...
Was sozusagen die Freiheit ist, auszuschalten.
Genau.
The choice is no.
So sieht's aus.
Das ist das, was Adobe hat.
Nicht können ist ja kein Statement. Nicht wollen ist ein Statement.
Wie soll man das denn bewusst abschalten können, wenn man es gar nicht einschalten kann?
Genau.
Da ist was dran. Da ist was dran.
Ich kann ja hier auch per VNC zuhause auf einen Rechner zugreifen, auf dem ich dann Flash abschalte.
Du hast so eine richtige Flatrate oder nur so eine... Ab irgendwann wird runtergedrosselt.
Jetzt erzähl doch erstmal die Geschichte, wie du in dieses Gerät gekommen bist.
Ich war ein Freund von mir, war in Amerika. In den Staaten. Und hat sich erstmal selber eins geholt, irgendwo in Texas. Der arbeitet bei der ESA.
Dallas, Houston.
Und war da in... Bei der NASA, genau. Houston? Nein, nicht in Houston. Wo die Saturn V und so was getestet haben. So Testgelände war das in der Nähe. Und da ist irgend so ein Kleines, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das Kaff heißt. Also hat er sich da halt sein iPad gekauft und war dann ein paar Tage auf der Konferenz. Und dann war er noch in New York. Und es ist original am Freitag, an dem es rauskam. Am wievielten? April war das. Das 3G ist er um...
30.
Ist er um 6 Uhr abends dahin. Das muss irgendwie 8 Minuten gewesen sein, nachdem die das gestartet haben.
Die haben abends aufgemacht?
Die haben tagsüber gesperrt worden. Die haben zwischen 4 und 5 glaube ich. Oder zwischen 5 und 6 haben die den Laden dicht gemacht, alles umgebaut für das neue iPad. Und dann aufgemacht.
Am Nachmittag? Achso, ich dachte die machen das nachts und dann machen sie früh morgens auf.
Vielleicht kann natürlich auch sein, dass es früh morgens...
Ja klar, die warten nicht noch einen ganzen Tag, wenn sie irgendwie sagen, dass sie an dem Tag was verkaufen.
Ich dachte ja sowieso ab Mitternacht und Zweifelsfall. Aber irgendwie hatten die da... Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ja, auf jeden Fall war der da und da war eine ewig lange Schlange. Dann hat er gesagt, nee, macht er nicht. Da stellt er sich nicht für an. Und hat er dann auch nicht getan, sondern ist dann einfach ein paar Stunden später gekommen und da war es dann reingehen in den Laden.
Hat er dann auch Glück gehabt, dass er nicht von den ganzen Kamerateams abgelöstet wurde, die wahrscheinlich alle noch rumlauern.
Und hat mir da mein Wunsch-iPad geholt. Also quasi das 32GB ist das jetzt mit UNTS. Mittlerweile hat man lange Wartezeiten drauf, glaube ich. Also ich hab echt Schwein gehabt.
Ich brauch unbedingt so ein Soundboard hier, mit ordentlich bestückten Sounds, damit man hier auch so Glückseligkeitsklänge erspielen kann.
Das brauchst du ein geiles Soundboard, dafür kann ich auch so machen.
Nee, nicht solche Glückseligkeit. Das war so ein bisschen anders. Mal gucken, vielleicht krieg ich ja hier noch ein Soundboard an Start. Eigentlich hab ich ja eins, ich hab bloß nicht so richtig tolle Klänge.
Genau, das haben Tweets jetzt seit anderthalb Wochen. Ich komm nie dazu, es zu benutzen, weil es ist wirklich egal, wo man es rausholt. Irgendjemand will immer drauf rumgrapschen. Also Leute reißen es ja geradezu fast aus der Hand. Aber das mit der SIM-Charakter, das war total easy. Um das jetzt mal kurz zu erzählen.
Genau, weil ich denke, das ist ja gerade so der Mittelpunkt. Also wir kommen gleich nochmal auf iPad im Allgemeinen. Aber bleiben wir doch erstmal beim 3G im Besonderen. Das heißt, der einzige wirkliche Unterschied zwischen den anderen Geräten ist angeblich mehr Gewicht. Das haben wir eben gerade mal so getestet, das fällt nicht weiter ins Gewicht. Und es hat oben diesen schwarzen Teil, wobei ich sagen muss, das sieht nicht schäbig aus. Also das ist irgendwie nett.
Aber das WLAN-Ding sieht da schon besser aus.
Ja, okay, gut. Sie haben sich schon ein bisschen Mühe gegeben mit dem Kunststoff.
Ja, das stimmt. Und es ist halt so ein kleines Fach an der Seite drin, wo man mit dem üblichen SIM-Kartenentfernungswerkzeug von Apple die SIM-Karte rausholt.
Also eine Büroklammer.
Nee, es ist sogar dabei.
Ja, dieses kleine Büroklammer-artige Teil.
Genau, dieses Teil ist wieder dabei. Und damit holt man da die SIM-Karte raus. Dann war da halt eine AT&T-SIM-Karte drin. Und...
Die quasi nicht aktiviert schon im Gerät mitverkauft wird.
Genau. Dass das ja dann in Deutschland anders läuft.
Da ist auch eine Karte drin. Deswegen schreibt der Rotum und kann die sofort aktivieren.
Ja, aber du hast ja drei verschiedene Optionen.
Also ich bin mal gespannt, wie es bei Auslieferung wird. Also bei Bestellung war es ja so, du kannst ja auswählen, was du gerne haben möchtest.
Genau.
Welche SIM-Karte?
Die Frage ist, was sie dir im Laden verkaufen. Das ist ja noch nicht klar, weil die verkaufen sie ja keine im Laden. Also das ist noch offen.
Genau, das werden wir alles sehen. Aber da ist die... Also ich hab das eingeschweißt bekommen in der Kiste. Und die AT&T-SIM-Karte war drin in dem Gerät. Und ich hätte quasi sofort anfangen können, damit loszusurfen. Welche ich sicherlich auch aufheben für, falls ich mal nach Amerika fahren sollte.
Dann kannst du es aktivieren.
Dann kann man es aktivieren. Und die Tarife sind ja relativ okay. Also es ist ja monatlich kündbar und so was. Und da kann man ja echt... Das ist ja mal ein relativ okayer Tarif für so ein...
Okay, aber du hast deine O2-Karte genommen. Und zwar nicht irgendeine, sondern deine zweite.
Genau, ich hab insgesamt drei SIM-Karten.
Genau, das ist ja das Maximum, was O2 auch ausgibt.
Genau, das ist das Maximum, was er ausgibt. Ich wollte eigentlich noch eine weitere bestellen, bis ich dann festgestellt habe, geht mir nicht.
Und die hast du dann mit der Schere angepasst?
Und die hab ich dann mit der Schere angepasst.
Und du hast sozusagen als Vorlage die AT&T-Karte, die schon drin war, genommen?
Genau. Und ich hab das mehr oder weniger so, ich hab das gar nicht so exakt gemacht, ich hab die so draufgehalten. Und ich hab mir vorher mal so ein paar SIM-Karten angeguckt, die sehen alle erstaunlich unterschiedlich aus. Ich dachte ja, so meiner treu blöden Naivität, der Chip wär immer genauso groß und sowas, aber sogar die Zahl der Kontakte unterscheidet sich teilweise. Und bitte? Das ist jetzt hier bei der, die ich jetzt drin habe zum Beispiel, bei der O2-SIM-Karte, da ist, also das, was ich nachher, was nach dem Abschneiden noch übrig war, ist eigentlich nur noch so die Chip-Kontakt-Fläche. Also jetzt ist alles so metallisch oben auf der Seite.
Ja, das ist ja nur Plastik.
Jaja, aber es gibt auch SIM-Karten, also es ist deutlich kleiner. Es gibt, ich hab unterschiedlichste, ich hab SIM-IO-Karten, ich hab O2-Karten, zwei verschiedene sogar. Nämlich, ich hatte noch eine zu Hause rumliegen, bevor ich eine Multisim hatte, eine etwas ältere. Da sieht der Chip ein bisschen anders aus. Die sehen alle ein bisschen anders aus. So ganz minimal. Die AT&T-Karte, die hier drin ist, hat zwei Kontakte weniger. Genauso wie diese SIM-IO-Karte hat auch zwei Kontakte weniger. Und da war erstmal so ein bisschen...
Die AT&T-Karte hat zwei Kontakte weniger, wahrscheinlich weil sie auch nicht so schnell Daten überträgt. Da haben sie gleich ein paar Kontakte weglassen. So viel Bandbreite brauchen wir ja nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, mal gucken. Ich hab hier eine hier. Genau, die hat die ja auch... Also die von O2.
Machen wir noch mal hier ein bisschen das Licht an, Jungs. Du hast auch noch so eine Lampe.
Mach mal an.
Dann sehen wir auch was.
Dann sehen wir was, was wir nicht sehen. Ja, und das ist jetzt so eine SIM-IO-Karte und die hat hier drei Kontakte auf jeder Seite. Und die O2-Karte hat vier Kontakte auf jeder Seite. Und dann ist die auch ein bisschen größer, der Chip da. Ich kann gerne, wenn du hier eine Büroklammer hast, die SIM rausholen oder so.
Mir ist das neu, dass es da so verschiedene Optionen gibt, wie viele Kontakte man auf einer SIM-Karte haben kann. Ich hab sogar eine Büroklammer als professioneller Apple-Anwender. Hat man ja sowas, ne? Wie soll ich sonst die Floppy-Disc rauskriegen?
Eben. Stimmt, die Büroklammer, die Apples Liebe zur Büroklammer ist eigentlich...
Dieses kleine Loch, wo man was reinsteckt und dann kommt was raus. Das fanden sie schon immer gut. Da ist das iPhone jetzt sozusagen der direkte Nachfolger. So, bevor wir dieses Gerät wirklich einmal...
Passt nicht rein.
Aha, eine incompatible, die ist beschichtet, ne?
Ich brauch ne Mikrobüroklammer.
Warte mal.
Hast du vielleicht ne Schere, dann kann man die bearbeiten, dann kann man auch aus dem Mikrobüro... Eine Mikro... Also es gibt tatsächlich Unterschiede zwischen SIM-Karten. Ich hab's nicht für möglich gehalten, aber die sehen alle ein bisschen anders aus. Aber im Wesentlichen mit ein bisschen...
Wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich korrigiert werden, ne?
Mit ein bisschen, wahrscheinlich kriegen wir jetzt einfach einen Link zur Wikipedia-Seite zugeschickt.
Bist du sicher, dass du nicht noch irgendwas übersehen hast, dass da nur so die Optik...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, da war tatsächlich... Also ja, da ist natürlich auch die Optik ein bisschen anders und sowas, aber da war einfach wirklich mehr Kontaktfläche drauf. Also sehr sicher.
Ich frage mal die Alvies in der Müllhalle, das interessiert mich jetzt gerade mal. Nicht, dass wir ihnen nur Stuss erzählen. Und nicht noch mehr Stuss erzählen. Muss ja auch nicht übertreiben, ne?
Ja, und dann muss man diese ein bisschen mit... Also man muss halt erahnen, welche Kontakte da... Ah, guck mal, hier. Nee, das ist eine mit drei, die sie da haben.
Was heißt ab? Guck mal, wir sind ja in einem Audio-Podcast.
Keine Ahnung, wofür sie auch diese Kontakte brauchen. Ich hab auch hier von... Also was ich genommen habe als Vorlage ist so ein Foto von Muscle Nerd, mit dem der das gemacht hat. Und der hat auch schon auf die zusätzlichen Kontakte hingewiesen, dass man die durchaus ignorieren kann einfach. Ja und grob in der richtigen Richtung geschnitten, so dass ich gesagt habe, alles klar, das sind die drei wichtigen Kontakte, die müssen wohl grob an der gleichen Stelle liegen, wo sie vorher lagen.
Ah okay, warte mal, ich hab das mal kurz nachgeschlagen. Also, die SIM-Karte hat tatsächlich acht Kontaktflächen, laut Spezifikation. Okay. Zwei davon sind reserviert.
Ah, alles klar.
Also es kann also sein, dass es Karten gibt, die zwar so aussehen, als hätten sie vier Kontakte, aber als hätten sie acht Kontakte, aber zwei davon werden nicht beendet.
Sind einfach Fake. Okay, gut. Und, äh, naja, lassen sie das wahrscheinlich bei anderen einfach weg. hab die dann so grob ausgeschnitten, man muss halt darauf achten, dass diese angeschnittene Ecke, muss die angeschnittene bleiben. Also, das ist ja nicht komplett rechteckig, sondern ist ja eine Ecke von der SIM-Karte angeschnitten, damit man in eine Richtung reingeht, ins Telefon. Und dann hab ich das so lange, bis es irgendwie in diese Schublade gepasst hat, diese SIM-Karte, und hab's dann reingesteckt und dann ging's. Also, APN noch eingetragen, klar.
So, es gab ja vor ein paar Tagen Berichte, irgendwie, also ich hab auch so ein bisschen mir die Augen gerieben, als ich das gelesen habe, wo war das? Glaube ich im FSDK-Log, irgendjemand meinte, dass das iPad sich wie ein Telefon verhalten würde und deswegen, also, das waren jetzt schon sehr laute Erkundungen.
Ja, da stand da was, dass dann die Anrufe dahin gehen würden oder sowas, ne?
Ja. Ich halte das für eine totale Ente und was dort wahrscheinlich passiert ist, ist so der Klassiker der Multisim-Anwendung. Ich hatte das auch. Und zwar wahrscheinlich deshalb, als ich das Teil bekommen hab, also ich hab meine Dritte noch nicht so mir schicken lassen, aber ich hab halt zwei. Hab halt eine in meinem iPhone und hab halt eine in meinem USB-Stick. Also so ein UMTS-Stick, tralla. Und ich glaub, als ich die bekommen hab, hab ich die irgendwie so ein bisschen vertauscht und dann hatte ich sozusagen die Neue in meinem iPhone. Und dann hat man so das Problem, dass wenn man online geht mit der anderen, die dann quasi die Primäre ist, dass dann automatisch in der Konfiguration für deinen Account, dass so eingestellt ist, dass dann eben die Anrufe auch zu der Karte gehen. Die natürlich von diesem Computer, der so ein UMTS-Stick hat, nicht beantwortet werden und deswegen bist du auf einmal nicht mehr erreichbar. Und glaub, genau dieser Effekt ist aufgetreten.
Das heißt, der Typ, der das geschrieben hat, müsste einfach nur seine Karte mal wieder tauschen?
Er kann ja nicht mehr, weil er eine davon bestinden hat, um sie ins Auto zu stecken.
Aber man kann, ich weiß nicht, muss man mal überlegen, weil ich hab das halt auch gemacht, die Prozedur. Ich glaube, man kann das schon telefonisch mit der Hotline lösen und irgendwie... Online ging das, glaub ich, nicht.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum Apple das Mikrosim benutzt hat?
Diese Mikrosim ist ja nichts anderes als weniger Plastik.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum man das unterscheiden kann. Die Kleinen benutzen jetzt Apple immer für Geräte, die gar nicht zum Telefonieren da sind. Dann könnte man die auch unterscheiden.
Das neue iPhone wird auch eine Mikrosim haben. Das neue iPhone ist noch nicht da, von daher...
Ich dachte, die haben das schon tausendfach auseinandergenommen.
Wenn man den Vietnamesen glauben darf und wenn man diesen Pennern von Gizmodo glauben darf, dann kommt das irgendwie...
Aber vielleicht ist das ja ein Hinweis darauf, dass man mit dem neuen iPhone nicht telefonieren kann.
Hätte sie gerne, damit alle so leiden müssen wie du jetzt gerade.
Also, wir fassen zusammen...
Doch, ich kann telefonieren, ich hab ja ein Telefon.
Wir fassen zusammen, laut Mobile Max ist das alles Quatsch. Dieses Gerät verhält sich, wie das sein soll. Es ist einfach ein UMTS-Teilnehmer, der Daten macht, der nicht telefonieren kann, aber der jetzt auch nichts irgendwie gegenüber dem Netz tut. Was verhindert, dass man mit seinem normalen Telefon weiterfahren kann. Das heißt auch, man braucht keinen separaten Datenvertrag. Also sich einen O2-Vertrag insbesondere zu klicken, wenn man sowieso schon einen hat, ist einfach Quark. Ist denn das in allen O2-Tarifen so, dass man sich eine Multisim zu schicken hat?
Ich glaube, das geht. Ich hab ja nur ein O2O, das finde ich das billigste, was die haben. Also ich hab ja keinen wunderbar Tarif.
Naja, ich hab irgendwie so ein...
Und man muss dann halt eine einwahlige Gebühr zahlen für diese Karte zusätzlich. Was, irgendwie 20 Euro oder sowas? Ja, sowas. Und dann kriegt man die zugeschickt. Und dann ist das alles total dufte. Man muss dann alle SIM-Karten auswechseln?
Also eigentlich ist das alles totale Verarsche. Man kann mit einem ganz normalen O2-Vertrag... Also diese O2-Angebot von Apple, was man sich da klicken kann, das ist eigentlich nur für Leute, die noch kein O2 haben. Wenn man O2 hat, dann geht das.
Oder wenn man noch keinen Datentreffer hat.
Sehr wahrscheinlich geht das auch bei allen anderen, die sowas anbieten. Jetzt weiß ich aber gerade nicht, wie das aussieht.
Ob die Multisims bieten?
Ja.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaub, das bieten nicht alle und vor allen Dingen nicht in allen Verträgen. Also ich meine, bei der Telekom kennen wir einen ganzen Spaß. Wie die sich ja nun...
Winden.
Wie die ja nun den totalen Vorteil daraus machen, dass man für nur, was kostet es zusätzlich, die Datenflatrate auch noch zusätzlich auf sein iPad, die man sowieso schon hat, auf sein iPad auszudehnen. Da haben sie doch so für iPhone User Kosten nur 30 Euro im Monat oder 15 oder ich weiß nicht was.
Keine Ahnung, ich mach mal hier einen Chat auf. Dann können wir uns über solche Fakten auch mal belehren lassen. Ich hatte da auch keine Zeit mehr, das Video anzuschauen. Ehrlich gesagt, mir wieder strebt auch, mich mit dieser Telekom zu beschäftigen. Weil gab es jemals einen Moment, wo du aufgehartmet hast, bei denen in den letzten paar Jahren?
Klar.
Das war doch immer nur...
Als ich gekündigt hab.
Ja, so war es halt. Aber da ich kein Kunde bin, kann ich da noch nicht mal kündigen. Also ich hab ja immer Schmerzen, wenn die irgendwas veröffentlichen. Das ist immer alles so, you spoiled it again. Du hast es schon wieder vergeigt.
Diese 4 Euro Datenflatrate pro Tag für das iPad.
Für jeden Tag oder für jeden Tag, den man es benutzt?
Du kannst es tageweise buchen. Also nicht als Vertrag.
Du musst erst mal online gehen und dann...
Du musst einfach schon auf der Website gehen. Keine Ahnung, wie man das macht. Aber 4 Euro pro Tag finde ich schon ziemlich happig. Insbesondere, weil es bei anderen für 10 Euro einen ganzen Monat gibt. Okay, da sind noch nicht ganz so viele Daten dabei, aber...
Was für Netze jetzt? Also du redest jetzt von E+.
Ja, E+, oder bei...
Ja, aber E-Plus hat nun wirklich ein echt mager ausgebautes RTS-Netz. Das hoffen wir mal berücksichtigt.
Das stimmt schon.
Und da, wenn die sich da andere Sachen leisten.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es ja Regionen in Deutschland, wo man an Telekom und wo davon nicht vorbeikommt. Da muss man dann...
Das gibt es auf jeden Fall. Und ich hätte auch ehrlich gesagt gar kein Problem, für ein besseres Netz auch mehr Geld zu bezahlen. Es sind nur immer so diese... Erstmal sind diese Tarife immer so, dass man sie nicht versteht. Also liest das durch und bist danach einfach keinen Moment schlauer. Und wenn du dich dann so halbwegs diesen Lawyer speak, der dir da irgendwie entgegenkommt mit ja, es ist alles toll, es ist alles einfach, es ist alles billig und dann so Stern und dann so fünf Balken Text mit so nee, es ist alles weder billig noch einfach und we own you.
Ich finde es mit diesen APNs mittlerweile wirklich langsam zu unverschämt, dass wenn du, auch wenn du, also ich, ein Freund von mir hat eine Datenflagrate bei Vodafone und hat dann nach Anleitung das sein iPhone entsprechend konfiguriert und was kriegt er am Ende des Monats eine Rechnung über 350 Euro, weil er ja die Daten über den falschen APN genutzt habe.
Das ist alles moderne Wege-Lagerate.
Und das ist wirklich Wege-Lagerate. Und dann hat er bei denen angerufen, da meinten die ja, nee, ist unser Fehler. Kümmern wir uns drum und drei Wochen später hat er sich nochmal eingegeldet, wussten sie nichts mehr davon und wollten jetzt sagen, nee, ist unser Fehler, das ist doch nicht unser Fehler. Wir haben niemals Schuld.
Also wenn ihr jemand von Vodafone oder Telekom oder so zuhört, würde bei O2 derzeit wirklich noch eine Ausnahme machen, weil die sich zumindest nicht ganz so schlecht benehmen. Ihr seid einfach, ihr habt echt ein Imageproblem, um es mal ganz zurückhaltend auszudrücken. Man nimmt schon gar nicht mehr an, dass man nicht übers Ohr gehauen wird. Ihr habt überhaupt keinerlei Bereitschaft, denen erstmal irgendwas zu glauben, weil es sich einfach am Ende immer rausstellt, dass Beschränkungen sind. Auch diese iPad-Tarife, die sie jetzt verkündet haben, ist nicht ohne Voice-over-IP und so.
Ohne Chat. Das finde ich das härteste.
Ohne Chat?
Na, ohne Instant-Messaging. Ja klar, selbstverständlich, weil Instant-Messaging ist doch bekannt dafür, dass es die Netz überlastet. Hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun, dass die Leute vielleicht keine SMS mehr verschicken könnten. Ja, das ist echt... So was in die Verträge zu schreiben, ist echt licherlich. Gerade bei so einem Gerät wie einem iPad, wo hier wirklich keine Gefahr besteht, dass irgendwelche SMS-Sachen dadurch kaputtgehen könnte. Ja, aber wollen wir nicht lieber über das Gerät sprechen, als die Tarife zu dem Gerät?
Wieso kann man damit eigentlich keine SMS verschicken? Lassen wir das. Also, du arbeitest jetzt wie lange mit dem Gerät?
1,5 Wochen habe ich das etwa.
Achso, Dennis, hast du noch irgendwelche Fragen?
Der Zeug ist entlassen.
Oh ja, keine Fragen. Wie lange arbeitest du jetzt damit? 1,5 Wochen.
Wie viel Geld hast du schon ausgegeben?
Ich will es nicht wissen. Ich schätze mal so um die 40 Euro. Ja, es ist jetzt. Ja, ja, ich bin jetzt allerdings, ich hab jetzt bisher nur, ich hab bisher alles über, also es ist ja irgendwie ganz merkwürdig. Man kann ja, man kann ja Apps schon im deutschen iTunes Store kaufen.
Außer denen von Apple.
Außer denen von Apple. Man kann aber nicht vom iPad aus auf den deutschen iPad Store zugreifen.
Nee, der Trick ist, man muss halt auf dem Rechner im deutschen Store die Sachen runterladen und dann aufs iPad sinken. So gehen auch die freien Sachen.
So gehen auch die freien Sachen. Und jetzt hab ich mir nochmal so einen amerikanischen Store-ID besorgt, um mir das wenigstens nochmal angucken zu können und auch mir ein paar Sachen runterladen zu können. Dafür habe ich jetzt allerdings kein Guthaben.
Das kann ich dir erklären, wie du das machen kannst.
Ich weiß auch, wie man es machen kann.
Und wir sollten das auch mal erklären, weil ich glaube, das würde viele Leute auch noch interessieren.
Wie man da rankommt. Also man muss sich, wie man an den amerikanischen Account kommt.
Genau, also man muss erstmal auch den US-Store wechseln. Dann geht man in den App Store. Sehr wichtig, dass man in den App Store geht und dass man nicht sagt, ich will einen neuen Account. Sondern man geht erstmal in den App Store, bevor man einen neuen Account hat und sucht sich irgendein freies, kostenloses Programm. Also kein freies. Genau, nicht die Diskussion jetzt schon.
Ein kostenloses, gefarktes Programm.
Genau, also ein kostenloses iPad-Programm heraussuchen oder auch ein iPhone-Programm, ist egal. Und dann möchte er natürlich von einem irgendwie Credentials haben. Er möchte trotzdem, dass man quasi einen Account hat, damit man diesen Kaufvorgang durchführen kann. Genau, auch wenn es sich dabei um Null Dollar handelt. Und nur wenn man das so macht, also nur wenn man eine App kauft, nicht wenn man einfach direkt sagt, ich möchte hier einen Account, hat man die Möglichkeit zu sagen, dass man das ohne Kreditkarte machen kann.
Das ist auch relativ versteckt, oder das war nicht so extrem offensichtlich, als ich das gemacht habe. Irgendwo muss man anklicken, Payment Method und dann musst du sagen, non.
Da wo du halt sonst sagen würdest, dass du halt Amex oder was auch immer hast, also irgendwelchen Kreditkartentyp. Da sagst du halt einfach, ich hab keine. Dann kannst du einen Account machen, also E-Mail-Adresse und sehr übliche Schlaß.
Adresse New York raussuchen.
Und dann hast du einen Account, der halt 0 Dollar Volumen hat und damit kannst du dann aber auch schon mal kostenlose Ups kaufen.
Zum Beispiel iBooks hab ich mir darüber runtergeladen.
Genau. Und wenn man dann halt auch noch Geld ausgeben will, also wenn man zum Beispiel Pages, Numbers und...
Keynote.
Keynote, genau. Danke. Auch noch haben will, da muss man halt Geld draufladen. Das ist die einfachste Methode, die man geht einfach zu Ebay, sucht nach iTunes-Coupons oder wie heißt das nochmal offiziell?
Giftcard oder?
Giftcard, irgendwie sowas. Wisst schon halt so diese Teile, die man im Supermarkt kauft, mit denen man sein Guthaben auflädt, also so eine Guthabenkarte. Sucht explizit nach US-Store, dass die halt auch dafür sind. Und dann klickt man die sich und in der Regel kriegt man dann von den Jungs schnell eine E-Mail zugeschickt, wenn sie einen nicht über den Tisch ziehen wollen. Und dann hat man halt diesen String und den kann man dann wiederum...
Also ich schicke die physische Karte gar nicht mehr zu?
Nein, nein, nein. Die schicken dir einfach nur den String. Und mehr willst du ja auch gar nicht, das machst du Copy-Paste. Wirfst du das dann eben, also sagst halt irgendwie, ich will hier so einen Coupon einlösen und dann hast du halt auf einmal den entsprechenden Betrag auf deinem Konto gut geschrieben und kannst damit auch kaufen. Und der Account gilt dann eben nur für US und man braucht eben für den deutschen dann immer noch den, den man wahrscheinlich sowieso schon hat, also einen separaten. Ein Account ist mal das so. Und das ist halt sehr lästig, weil auch so für, wenn du halt Software-Updates haben willst, musst du dann immer erstmal in dem jeweiligen Store eingeloggt sein. Ich war dann am Anfang etwas überrascht, weil mir iTunes mehr Updates angezeigt hat, als ich tatsächlich Retrieven konnte zum Beispiel. So ne Geschichten. Und das hat dann damit zu tun, dass ich dann eben in den anderen Store habe erstmal wechseln müssen und da dann wieder in die Updates zu holen für die Programme und dann wieder zurückzuwechseln in den Deutschen und so. Also es ist alles ein bisschen affig, aber es geht. Und so kann man eben auch zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt das schon machen. Ich vermute mal, das Ganze wird jetzt Ende Mai sowieso dann kein Thema mehr sein, weil dann kann man dann eben einfach nochmal in den Store und dann kann man dann auch auf dem iPad die Applikationen aktualisieren, was ja derzeit eben generell nicht geht.
Na doch, ich kann die Sachen, die ich über den amerikanischen Store mir runtergeladen habe, die kann ich mir natürlich auch auf dem iPad aktualisieren.
Achso, in den US-Store kommst du?
Ich komme in den US-Store, komme ich Problemlos sagen? Bin ich jetzt auch sogar hier drin?
Ah, dann könnte ich ja sozusagen über das iPad mir meine US-Applikationen aktualisieren.
Genau.
Ja, okay, das macht ja auch Sinn. Also der deutsche Store geht auf jeden Fall vom iPad nicht.
Und das ist der Hauptgrund, warum ich das bisher noch nicht gemacht habe, weil das nervt mit den Updates. Und wenn ich jetzt hier 30 Dollar an irgendwelche Programme investiere, die ich dann nur schwer aktualisieren kann, da warte ich doch lieber noch die paar Tage.
So wie ist denn der Empfang?
Die WLAN-Probleme, von denen man hier was liest, also so, dass es irgendwie aus dem WLAN rausfliegt und so was, habe ich. Habe ich auch. Nervt.
Achso, rausfliegst du.
Ich fliege raus.
Das hatte ich nicht. Ich hatte nur, dass ich die ganze Netze nicht gesehen habe, also dass ich überhaupt nicht joinen konnte, aber rausgeflogen bin ich noch nicht. Hast du auch deine Display-Helligkeit dann angepasst?
Nee, ich habe da bisher noch gar nichts gemacht, weil es ist im Endeffekt dank 3G nicht so nervig, weil dann surft er halt über 3G.
Und das funktioniert so, wie man das vom iPhone kennt.
Und das funktioniert so, wie man das vom iPhone kennt. Das ist wirklich, also jetzt die WLAN-Probleme kriegen sicherlich noch in den Griff, gehe ich mal von aus, dass das Software-Probleme sind.
Haben sie doch gesagt, da gibt es irgendwas, oder?
Haben sie angekündigt, dass sie das per Software fixen wollen.
Genau. Was ich sehr lustig finde, ist, GPS scheint mir beim iPhone genauer zu sein, oder besser zu sein, als beim iPad. Ach. Das ist GPS. Genau. Aber ansonsten nichts zu bemeckern. Das funktioniert so, wie es soll. Wie ist bei dir die Akkulaufzeit?
Schwer zu sagen.
Also...
Also generell kann man glaube ich festhalten, das Ding hält lange. So von diesem, dass man da drei Tage mit arbeiten kann. Damit, weiß ich nicht, das hängt dann eben auch sehr davon ab, mit was man da arbeitet.
Das Gefühl hab ich auch.
Also Spiele sind da definitiv einfach mehr Sacka als andere Sachen.
Ich hab das Gefühl, dass Net News Fire aus irgendeinem Grund ziemlich saugt.
Keine Ahnung, benutze ich nicht. Aber... Ich muss auch sagen, ich bin halt da auch ein bisschen drauf hängen geblieben. Also sind wir jetzt schon so bei Use-Cases. Dann bleiben wir erstmal beim Akku. Also generell kann man sagen, das Ding hält lange. Das hält einfach lange. Das ist irgendwie eine ganz andere Erfahrung. Das ist irgendwie nicht wie ein iPhone und das ist auch nicht wie ein Laptop. Sondern wenn du das so rumliegen hast und 4-5 mal am Tag benutzt, dann kannst du da wahrscheinlich wirklich mehrere Tage mit einer Akkuladung überleben.
Ich hatte auch so, wenn der Akku anzeigt, so die Warnung kommt, jetzt nur noch 20%. Das ist ja beim iPhone, das ist ja, oh, oh.
Jetzt aber schnell.
Jetzt aber schnell. Ich hab nicht auf die Uhr geguckt, wie lange ich da noch hatte, aber anderthalb bis zwei Stunden wären es schon gewesen sein tatsächlich. Also es war wirklich Dauersurfen. Und das einfach so benutzen wie bisher, das ist echt angenehm. Das hat echt viel Spaß gemacht.
So, aber jetzt die eigentliche Frage, die ja auch Dennis Brennt interessiert ist, was macht er damit eigentlich? Wofür braucht man dieses Scheißteil eigentlich?
Ohne Multitasking ist finde ich noch ein bisschen so, hm.
Ich heiße das jetzt so die Revolution und so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was man damit macht, aber das wird garantiert total geil gehen.
Aber was machst du denn die ganze Zeit?
Sitze zu Hause auf der Couch und surfst so ein bisschen? Und lässt dein Laptop erstmal stehen?
Genau. Ja, da ich ja tagsüber im Augenblick keinen Rechner brauche, also ich brauche meinen Macbook. Nee, ich hab auf Arbeit einen Rechner gestellt bekommen. Und hab ich bisher immer das Macbook mitgeschleppt, einfach so, wer weiß, wo ich, also wenn ich bei meiner Freundin übernachte und so, dann möchte man ja abends vielleicht noch mal irgendwie Mails lesen oder News lesen oder ein bisschen casual rumsurfen, sag ich jetzt mal. Jetzt nicht so dieses Hard-to-Work-Ding. Und hab da bisher mal das Macbook für mitgenommen und das lasse ich jetzt einfach zu Hause nehmen, stattdessen das iPad mit, was um einiges weniger wiegt und was viel besser in den Rucksack reinpasst und viel entspannter ist. Und das ist so der Anwendungsfall. Dafür ist es wirklich ziemlich gut. Also so um News zu lesen, ein bisschen Twitter-Zeug zu machen, hier und da mal eine Mail zu schreiben, dafür ist es echt großartig und funktioniert, wie ich finde, gerade das Surfen funktioniert viel besser als auf dem iPhone. Und es ist anspruchsloser als ein Macbook. Also bei meinem Macbook, z.B. wenn ich das aufklappe, das braucht man im Moment zum Aufwachen, dann musst du sich erst mit dem WLAN verbinden, dann muss das und das passieren, dann stürzt du Programme ab oder so was, das ist einfach so, das braucht man ein bisschen aufwarten. Das Ding holt man raus, klappt es wirklich auf, bap, ist sofort online, egal.
Schaust du das iPad auf, wie machst du das denn?
Na, weil ich ja hier diese Schutzhülle habe.
Achso.
Dann klappe ich es tatsächlich auf, bzw. drück die Taste und mach es an. Und ich kann schon anfangen zu surfen, während es sich noch mit dem WLAN verbindet, im Zweifelsfall. Ich finde es wesentlich...
Diese Schutzhülle ist ja schon ein bisschen metrosexuell, oder?
Ja, schon. Aber sie ist unglaublich hässlich, aber praktisch. Ich finde die gar nicht.
Ich finde es nur, wenn du auf der Couch sitzt, wo machst du denn die Umschlagseite? Machst du dann auch so nach hinten, oder?
Also ich mach das im Wesentlichen... Also man kann das hier hinten so praktisch einhaken, wie jetzt wahrscheinlich alle schon mal auf Bildern gesehen haben. Und dann hat man so...
Ja, wenn du so schräg auf dem Tisch stehst, ist das klar. Aber wenn du es jetzt in der Hand hältst...
Aber es präferiert halt den Landscape-Modus. Und der Landscape-Modus ist eigentlich, das finde ich extrem inkonsequent derzeit noch beim iPad so. Du hast dieses Teil, das sagt Landscape. Und du hast einen Dog, das sagt Portrait.
Ich nutze es eigentlich nur im Landscape-Modus.
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
Na ich nutze es eigentlich fast nur im...
Portrait-Modus?
Na stimmt nicht ganz. Also bei Spielen eher so im Landscape-Modus.
Das kommt ja auch immer gerade drauf an, wie man gerade so Bock hat, oder?
Jaja, auch bei Webseiten, wie gut die...
Also bei Movies musst du ja Landscapes machen....
sind und so weiter. Da willst du halt manchmal eher Landscape haben, damit du da größere Kontes hast und so.
Und beim Brausen genauso, wenn irgendwie alles gerade zu klein ist zum Lesen, dann drehst du einfach.
Aber wenn ich da mal kurz einhaken darf, also wo ich da auch voll bestätigen kann, was du da machst, so dieses im Netz surfen, dieses alberne Surfen, das ist tatsächlich mit diesem iPad was anderes. Also das ist wirklich, man macht es anders und man macht es echt mal auf dem Sofa. Laptop auf dem Sofa, das ist irgendwie der Feind. Insbesondere wenn man Kinder hat. Das geht gar nicht. Die kommen dann mal angerannt und hauen dir da auf den Deckel oder auf die Tastatur oder beides gleichzeitig. Aber auch ohne Kinder würde ich sagen, ist einfach so dieses lästige, man nimmt sich mal so eben das Internet und dann guckt man da mal kurz rein. Das ist wie so ein permanentes Fenster ins Netz. Und dann legst du das irgendwie beiseite. Und was ich ja richtig geil finde, das sind diese 2001-Momente. Du weißt, worauf ich anspiele? Na, es gibt doch 2001, Stanley Kubrick.
Wo dann die Computer die Welt übernehmen.
Ja, aber bevor sie das tun. Also es gibt ja da diese ersten, da kommen dann erstmal die Affen. Und dann geht das ja los mit ta ta ta. So diese Reise zu dieser Station. Und dann gibt's ja dann später also zum Mond und dann, dann, dann, dann, dann fiept der Monolith und so und dann irgendwie Cut und dann kommt der dritte Teil, der den Hauptteil des Films aufnimmt, wo sie dann mit dieser Mission Richtung Jupiter fahren um mal rauszukriegen, was denn diese Monolithen auf sich hat. Und da ist ja diese Besatzung und ganz zu Anfang also dieses dritten Teils siehst du so ihr Daily Life.
Wie hat er den Jog die ganze Zeit über?
Ja, der eine Jog in diesem runden Teil und dann sitzen sie aber da und konsumieren ihr Frühstück und die Nachrichten. Und dann hat er da so sein Frühstück in so einer Krankenhausartigen Tablett-Variante in verschiedenen Farben. Und links daneben liegt also so ein iPad. Also guckst dir an, das Teil liegt einfach flach auf dem Tisch. Da läuft dann halt Fernsehen drauf in dem Moment, also so Video mit irgendwie den Berichten, was so vor ein paar Tagen das dann mal geschafft hat von der Erde, so mit leichter Latenz halt in dieses Teil. Und es ist einfach genau das. Es ist so dieses Lesen oder Nachrichten konsumieren während des Essens. Und damit schafft es dieses iPad tatsächlich, die Tageszeitung zu emulieren, sag ich jetzt mal. Ich will ja noch nicht von Essen sprechen. Aber ich hab mit größter Freude wirklich dieses Gerät beim Frühstücken benutzt, so einfach da liegen gehabt und mich halt durch Webseiten, Newsfeeds, was auch immer durchgelegt. Dafür ist es echt sagenhaft, weil es nimmt nicht... Also wenn du ein Laptop auf dem Tisch stehen hast, ist es echt, also auf dem Essenstisch, ist es wirklich unangenehm. So auch anderen Leuten gegenüber. Das iPad ist immer noch unangenehm an anderen Leuten gegenüber, aber es trägt nicht mehr so dick auf.
Ja, es ist irgendwie... Es ist echt easy. Also das ist so... Während zum Beispiel so dieses... Okay, jetzt habe ich tatsächlich... Jetzt lade ich sie gerade mal so ein bisschen, weil der Akku wirklich gerade runter war. Aber der normale Betriebsmodus bei so einem Laptop ist ja auch aufklappen und Strom anschließen. Weil eigentlich so dieses... Ja, wir haben da ein Akku drinne und damit halten wir tatsächlich auch mal für einen Atemzug durch.
Das hat sich aber jetzt mit den neuen Geräten noch ein bisschen geändert, wenn die jetzt bei ihren neuen Stunden sind, ne?
Wenn sie die tatsächlich schaffen. Also ich bin...
Naja, aber du kannst es schon... Du weißt, dass du jetzt hier stundenlang sitzen kannst und dass es nicht leer ist. Also man kann da schon einen Tag mit auskommen irgendwie.
Ja, aber man muss es immer noch... Akku muss man immer noch im Hintergrund behalten. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man für das iPad keinen Netzteil mitnehmen muss, allerdings ist das schon mal erstens wesentlich kleiner und handlicher als bei so einem MacBook. Und zum zweiten, der Normalbetriebsmodus ist tatsächlich... Da steckt nichts drin, man hat einfach nur das Gerät und da sind keine Kabel, die da irgendwie rausgucken und so, das finde ich schon sehr angenehm. Also das ist wirklich noch ein echter Vorteil gegenüber so einem großen Laptop. Also man kriegt schon irgendwie mit, da hat so ein kleiner... Da hat so ein Shift stattgefunden hinzu... Da ist es sehr iPod-ig oder sehr iPhone-ig.
Was ich ja bemerkt habe, ist, dass das iPad an meinem Laptop hier, ich hab hier so ein Core 2 Duo von Ende 2006, also der erste Core 2 Duo, dass es daran nicht auflädt. Und zwar in beiden Ports nicht. Das geht nur bei den neueren Rechnern.
Also bei meinem geht es, aber das lädt langsam halt.
Ja, aber bei meinem lädt es gar nicht, das steht richtig da...
Kein Wunder, guck dir mal das Netzteil an, von dem iPad, was da drauf steht.
Das ist nämlich...
Das Netzteil liefert 2,1 Ampere. Also richtig viel. So, während normaler USB-Port halt ein halbes Ampere per Spezifikation und die späteren Macs 1 Ampere geliefert haben. Verstehe ich das jetzt richtig, dass die neuen MacBooks einen 2 Ampere Modus haben oder sowas?
Oder eineinhalb oder so? Eineinhalb, ich glaube genug fürs iPhone.
Na, das iPhone braucht eins.
Das braucht eins? Ich glaube, das braucht ein bisschen mehr als eins. Warte mal, ich kann ja nochmal das andere Netzteil rausholen, was das dann für technische Daten da drauf hat. Da muss man jetzt nämlich immer darauf achten, dass man auch immer das richtige Netzteil dran hat. Dass man, also, ist jetzt nicht schlimm, wenn man sein iPhone mit einem iPad-Netzteil lädt.
Aber... Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich jetzt immer wirklich mal die Ladestärke des Netzteils dran geschrieben hab, mit einem Adding, damit ich die Dateien runterscheiden kann. Und mir nie Wunder.
0,15A? 42 Volt, bla bla bla, 0,45A. Was ist 0,45A? Das ist die Ampere?
Nee, was hast du denn da? Ein iPod-Netzteil?
Also das hier ist vom iPod, und das ist das iPad-Netzteil, was ich jetzt am iPad auch dranstecken habe.
Also hier ist mein iPad-Netzteil. 10 Watt USB-Power-Adapter. Und da steht dran irgendwo 2,1A.
Output 5,1V, 2,1A. Und das hier hat 1A.
Achso, du warst da bei dem Input. Das sind irgendwie so die Spannungs-Sicherungs-Schritte.
Habe ich doch keine Ahnung von dem.
Habe ich auch keine Ahnung davon. Auf jeden Fall ist 2 mehr als 1. Da kommt halt ordentlich Strom raus, ne?
Lädt trotzdem ziemlich langsam. Das dauert schon eine Weile, bis so ein Akku voll ist. Aber es dauert auch eine Weile, bis er leer ist. Ja, also was kann man auch mitmachen?
Also ich kann dir mal sagen, was bei mir bisher funktioniert hat. Wo ich wirklich sagen muss, wo ich auch hingehe zu diesem Gerät. Wo ich mich entscheide. Also ich habe wirklich so die Situation, iPhone, iPad, Laptop steht so vor mir. Was benutze ich für was? Und ich fühle mich interessanterweise wirklich bei unterschiedlichen Szenarien zu unterschiedlichen Geräten hingezogen. Am Ende der Woche, wenn ich das nicht mache, dann ist es ja auch ein bisschen nicht nach wie vor, wenn ich vor allem, wie Dennis so schön sagt, Multitasking mache. Also wenn es mir wirklich darum geht, auch nicht nur Informationen so in meinen Kopf zu kriegen, sondern natürlich auch in andere Dokumente reinzubekommen. Was weiß ich, URLs, die man sich mehr Copypaste, Schnittkiste und Gedöns. Du kennst das schon. Viel chatten. Also weil man auch in so einem Massive-Modus ist. Und dieses extrem nerdige Computer benutzen, wo die anderen einen ja sowieso schon immer so komisch angucken, was man da die ganze Zeit macht. Und wenn man eher sich so auf deren Level herunterlässt und sagt, naja, jetzt schau ich mir mal eine Webseite an. Manchmal kommt das ja auch vor. Dann treibt es mich gleich schon wieder weg von dem Mac. Und ich weiß gar nicht warum. Wahrscheinlich weil das so ein bisschen, da sind wir wieder so bei lean back und lean forward. Also in so ein Macbook guckt man immer rein. Dann ist man immer nach vorne gebeugt. Du kennst den Unterschied mit lean forward und lean back Medium.
Die wo man sich noch hinten lehnt.
Genau, Fernsehen, da lehnt es sich halt ins Sofa. Und das interessante ist, das iPad ist so ein bisschen das lean back Medium für Internet. Und von daher denke ich mal, wenn diese ganzen Videostreaming-Dienste erstmal so richtig am Start sind, dann wird es richtig spannend, weil das Teil ist eigentlich ein 1A-Konsumgerät für Live-Video oder überhaupt für Video.
Also ich finde eine tolle Anwendung darauf erstaunlicherweise Fotos. Das klingt total banal. Das haben sie auf der Keynote auch vorgeführt und ich hab gedacht, ja Fotos, wie langweilig ist das denn? Aber ich war zum Beispiel gestern auf einer Party in Leipzig, wo wir ein paar Leute getroffen haben, die, wir waren letztes Jahr zusammen alle auf der Krim in der Ukraine und hatten viel Spaß. Und irgendwann fiel mir so ein Moment mal, ich hab noch die Fotos da drauf auf dem iPad und dann hab ich das Ding halt geholt, was ich nicht dabei hatte. Und das ist erstaunlich kommunikativ. Man steht da in dieser Runde rum und irgendjemand hält das Ding dann und dem wird der Arm noch relativ kurze Zeit lahm, weil es doch relativ schwer ist. Dann switcht man da so durch, dann sitzen alle Leute daneben und dann reicht man es auch mal so kurz rum oder dreht es mal oder sowas. Also wirklich so diese Demosituation, wie sie Apple sich erträumt hat, die war in dem Fall gegeben. Und da schlägt das ein Laptop um Klassen. Also schon allein dafür, weil wir haben gestanden und haben keinen Tisch gebraucht. Und einen Laptop reißt man auch nicht mal eben so rum in so einem Maße, sondern dann versammeln sich alle eher um den Laptop herum. So diese Momente, das ist echt, das ist wirklich toll. Also Fotos angucken, darauf geht ganz großartig. Was auch erstaunlich gut geht, ist zu zweitsurfen, wenn man sich gegenüber sitzt am Tisch. Also einer hat das quasi im Normalmodus vor sich, liegt das so vor sich, und die andere Person kann dann zwar Kopf über, aber kann mit drauf gucken und kann dann sehen, was da passiert und kann Hinweise geben. Oder man kann so ein bisschen drüber sprechen. Das geht bei einem Laptop auch überhaupt nicht. Klar, kann man sich da nebeneinersetzen, aber das ist halt immer gleich Stühlerücken angesagt, weil man sitzt normalerweise in einer Kneipe nicht nebeneinander, sondern man sitzt sich gegenüber. Und das sind solche Momente, die mit dem iPad viel, viel besser funktionieren.
Ja, die andere Sache neben der reinen Brauserei sind Spiele. Und ich bin ja nun wirklich kein Spieletyp. Mehrfach durchklingen lassen. Ich bin einfach nicht so ein Spieletyp. Ich bin zwar immer mal wieder so ein bisschen hängen geblieben bei dem ein oder anderen Game.
Du brauchst ja die iPhone, ne, die iPod Games damals hier voll Zoomer und Bejeweled und all sowas.
Jaja, klar.
Was hast du denn so an Spielen? Was kannst du denn empfehlen?
Auch so viele sind noch gar nicht. Ich hab jetzt vor allem auch erstmal viele nochmal gespielt, die so in einer iPad-Version rauskamen, die ich schon kannte. Galcon.
Okay, das hab ich mir bisher noch gespart.
Angry Birds find ich ganz großartig.
Was ist das? Da muss man mit den Vögeln, den Schweinchen, umschießen oder so.
Das ist so super. Ja, du hast da irgendwie immer so verschiedene Arten von Vögeln, die so unterschiedliche Durchschlagskraft und Flugverhalten haben. Und hast dann immer so links so eine Zwille und rechts so eine Konstruktion aus Glas, Holz, Stein und dahinter sich verbergenden grünen Schweinchen unterschiedlicher Größe. Und du musst es halt schaffen, mit dem vorgegebenen Reservoir an Vögelchen diese Schweinchen irgendwie wegzutrümmern. Das ist wirklich sowas von cute und cool. Weil du musst halt drüber nachdenken, wie du da wirklich strategisch deine Vögel da einsetzt und du musst halt gut zielen und so. Und die dann immer so brumm mit dem Finger dann halt diese Zwille nach hinten ziehen und dann den Vogel im richtigen Winkel, an der richtigen Stelle, im richtigen Moment halt irgendwo gegenhauen. Teilweise haben die noch so einen Afterburner-Modus, dann tappst du, während sie fliegen, nochmal nach und dann verhalten die sich irgendwie anders, fliegen wieder zurück oder fliegen schneller oder sonst was. Oder teilen sich in mehrere Vögelchen auf und so. Also das ist auch einer der Verkaufshits derzeit im App Store und ich verstehe warum.
Also ich hab hier so ein bisschen Worms drauf gespielt, das fand ich ganz nett.
Ja, Worms hab ich auch, aber hab ich noch nicht so viel Zeit mit verbracht. Dieses Labyrinth-Game, was ja schon auf dem iPhone sehr beliebt war, das rockt auf dem iPad irgendwie auch noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das finde ich, also auf dem... Ich hab das Gefühl, dass dadurch, dass das iPad ein gewisses Gewicht hat und eine gewisse Trägheit, erinnert's mehr an dieses echte Spiel als die iPhone Version.
Wobei ich in beiden Varianten sagen muss, ich finde sie haben irgendwie das mit dieser Bewegung der Kugeln noch nicht so richtig hinbekommen. Also es ist einfach dieses, wie man es bewegt und wie diese Kugel darauf reagiert, das ist nicht so, wie es wär, wenn das Ding wirklich so in Labyrinth wär. Und schlimmer noch, dieser merkwürdige 3D-Modus, den sie da drin haben, dass wenn du einen Teil dann bewegst, hast du dann immer so diese Holzkanten aus unterschiedlichen Winkeln. Das entspricht auch überhaupt nicht der tatsächlichen Bewegung und von daher irritiert es mich eher noch, als dass es mir in irgendeiner Form behilflich ist. Das findest du gut gemacht. Was hab ich noch ausprobiert? Hier Flight Control, was Dennis ja schon bis zur Vergasung gespielt hat. Und das ist vielleicht auch das beste Beispiel, wo das iPad auch wirklich eine komplett neue Kategorie aufmacht. Weil Flight Control auf dem iPhone, das spielst du alleine. Aber Flight Control auf dem iPad, das bockt halt auch mit zwei oder drei Leuten.
Das wird sowieso noch ein Ding werden.
Ja, es ist ja nicht nur Multitouch, es ist auch irgendwie mehr Personenspielen.
Das wird so banale Brettspiele, aber wirklich eigene Kategorien, die erst dafür entstehen werden. Das wird so richtig rocken.
Das glaub ich auch. Also da ist wirklich eine ganze Menge Luft und da ist auch eine Menge zu holen und dass wirklich mehrere Leute gleichzeitig an irgendwas rumfummeln können. Es gibt ja auch dieses Air Hockey und so weiter. Es gibt ja zahlreiche Varianten. Das macht halt einfach mit diesem größeren Screen sehr viel Sinn. Hast du gesehen, dass da einer mal ausprobiert hat, wie multitouchy das eigentlich ist? Genau, elf. Ich frage mich, warum es elf sind.
Vielleicht doch Porno.
Ich fühlte mich an eine Geschichte erinnert. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, ich glaube es war Beethoven und, ach Gott, hier von diesen ganzen superbekannten klassischen Komponisten. Da gab es mehrere, die dann auch so halbwegs zur gleichen Zeit gelebt haben. Ich begebe mich jetzt gerade auf dünnes Eis. Es hat dir auch völlig egal, wer das war.
Drei Typen, die Klavier spielen konnten.
Drei Typen, die irgendwie so Composer waren. Und der eine meinte irgendwie, ich kann alles spielen, was du mir gerade komponierst. Und dann dachte der sich so, hm, hm, hm. Und dann hatte er halt was irgendwie komponiert, wo er dann irgendwie mit der einen Hand ganz links unten und mit der anderen Hand ganz rechts oben war. Und dann sollte er in der Mitte noch einen Ton anschlagen.
Dann hätte ich eine Nase genommen.
Ja, hat er nicht gemacht, hat er nicht geschafft, aber dann hat der andere gezeigt, wie man es macht. Dann hat er die Nase genommen. Daran muss ich denken, weil das iPad genau elf Berührungspunkte hat. Du kannst die eine Hand auf die andere Hand nehmen und theoretisch noch mit der Nase auf dem iPad auch noch irgendwas drücken.
Verstehe, und deswegen haben sie gesagt...
Porno, wo willst du denn deine Nase reinhalten?
Na eben nicht die Nase.
Ach, reden wir jetzt nicht.
Reden wir jetzt nicht zu Ende. Ich hab's mir angedeutet.
Steve mag keinen Porn.
Ja, das hat er heute deutlich gemacht.
Das ist Bebe.
Funktioniert aber trotzdem.
Angeblich, wenn man Kinder hat, würde man das anders sehen mit dem Porn. Ja, hat er gesagt.
Siehst du das jetzt anders, seitdem du es siehst?
Noch nicht.
Noch nicht, okay. Aber es geht trotzdem, also YouPorn geht.
Äh, nein.
Die Webseite?
Ist das noch Fleisch oder nicht?
Die sind offensichtlich gerade dabei, alles auf HTML umzuschalten.
Hat sich da in den letzten Tagen was geändert? Ich hab auch bei YouPorn nachgeschaut und da gab's nur so komische Demo-Clips. Aber nicht The Real Thing. Die haben ja auch ihre ganzen Videos im Wesentlichen noch als FLV tatsächlich. Also die sind ja noch gar nicht auf H264 umgeschaltet.
Das ist jetzt hier nicht... So, ich hab jetzt mal hier einfach eingeklickt.
Ich bestätige Dinge, ich seh das hier, der Max guckt hier gerade YouPorn.
Echt, das habt ihr jetzt eingeschaltet? Nein, wie geil.
Doch!
Was würde Steve Jobs sagen?
Tja, das hat er jetzt davon.
Das ist neu. Das ist neu, das ist ganz neu. Leid steht da aber. Ja, stimmt, das ist neu.
Wahrscheinlich haben die einfach noch nicht alles konvertiert oder so was, aber... In diesen flachen Markt...
Da müsste es ja auch beim iPhone gehen, ne? Wir machen mal kurz ne Sendepause.
Also das...
Das muss wirklich brandneu sein.
So, jetzt hab ich die Sendung getötet. Tut mir leid.
Echt, das ist ja erstaunlich. Aber mich wundert das nicht. Aber wir kommen ja da wahrscheinlich eh gleich noch zu diesem ganzen Thema mit Flash und so weiter. Leider müssen wir das ja nochmal aufgreifen. Update, welcome to our iPad-Site. Tatsächlich, we are now re-encoding our video archive to make all our videos.
Ach, da gibt's auch Text?
Aber runterladen noch als FLV sozusagen. Aber sie konvertieren also den ganzen Kram jetzt irgendwie auch.
Vielleicht ist es tot.
Das gibt ganz neue Bereiche dafür.
Das war absehbar. Von was haben wir jetzt gerade abgekommen?
11 Touch-Punkte.
Genau. Und das mit der Nase.
Mit der langen Nase. Ja, ihr langen Nasen.
Was ich eine total geile Anwendung darauf finde, ist Instapaper. Hast du dir das mal angeguckt?
Jaja, Instapaper ist ja insofern nicht neu. Ich hab's bloß auf dem iPad noch nicht gekauft.
Das ist teuer als.
Das ist aber wie toller?
Das ist super. Ich würde behaupten, das ist eine der Killer-Applikationen fürs iPad.
Da-da!
Da-da! Ich konnte mit Instapaper vorher nicht viel anfangen.
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Instapaper ist eine Seite, du richtest dir so ein Bookmarklet ein, oben in deiner Menüleiste im Browser. Und wenn du da dann draufklickst, dann wird sozusagen, legt der dir ein globales Bookmark oder sowas an.
Das ist doch erstmal einfach. Instapaper ist eine Anwendung, die dir das Offline-Lesen von Dokumenten ermöglichen soll.
Punkt.
Du surrst irgendwie was, du sagst, das würde ich mir gerne später mal anlesen. Und dann nimmst du dir so ein Bookmarklet und sagst irgendwie to Instapaper. Und dann wird das in diese Instapaper-Webseite hineinkommuniziert, dass du diese URL gerne dir merken möchtest. Und dann merkt er sich das.
Du meintest das ist so wie das Texta Webclip.
Wenn das sowas ist.
Das ist so ein JavaScript in der Bookmark versteckt, der irgendwie den Bereich der Seite, den du dir auswählst, zu Texta hoch lädt.
Ja, so. Und dann hast du halt die Applikation Instapaper und die lädt das dann halt irgendwie runter, so. Und das heißt, du musst dann eben, während du noch online bist auf deinem iPad oder auf deinem iPhone dieses Instapaper einmal starten, weil das kann ja nicht im Hintergrund laufen, wir wissen das ja. Und holst dich dann den ganzen Kram eben so offline und kannst dann irgendwie einstellen, wie gut er das machen soll, was weiß ich. Hab jetzt schon eine Weile lang nicht mehr angeschaut, weil ich hatte immer so diesen Use Case nicht so richtig.
Es ist super geeignet, um lange Artikel zu lesen.
Aber was ist da dann anders, als sich einen normalen Bookmark zu machen?
Also bei dieser Applikation, dass du das lesen kannst, wenn du auch kein Netz hast.
Also nicht nur das. Der nimmt halt den Browser weg. Der nimmt wirklich nur den Text und reduziert es auf den Text total.
Aber das kannst du einstellen, dass er das auch wirklich die komplette Seite nimmt.
Ja, das geht. Ich kann man auch sagen View und Browser. Und man kann halt, man kann einstellen die Textgröße, man kann einen Font auswählen, man kann sagen, ob man helles oder ein dunkles Seam haben kann. Man kann sogar die Spaltenbreite flexibel einstellen, was ich immer besonders wichtig finde, weil ich mag eher so schmale Spalten, weil ich finde, dann liest es sich angenehmer. Und man kann halt wirklich sehr detailliert eingehen, bestimmen, wie so ein Text aussehen soll. Und das ist großartig, um längere Texte zu lesen. Weil bei Spiegel online längeren Text zu lesen auf der Webseite, das geht ja schon nicht nur dadurch nicht, dass man Multitasking hat und die ganze Zeit über abgelenkt wird, sondern es geht auch darum nicht, weil da überall ständig Werbebanner sind und da eine Umfrage und da diskutieren sie mit. Das ist einfach nur noch Text. Und Bilder, wenn sie drin sind, sind die noch drin, mit etwas Glück. Ich weiß nicht, welchen cleveren Algorithmus die dahinter haben. Es funktioniert auch unterschiedlich gut, klar. Aber auf eigenen Webseiten hat man wirklich nur den Text, der im Artikel drin stand. Ganz, ganz großartig.
Na, dann kaufe ich mir das mal.
Find ich, lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Was ich noch mal angeguckt habe, sind iBooks und Kindle. Also diese Kindle-Applikation.
Und?
Die war sowas, was mich auf dem iPhone immer eher weniger gereizt hat. Aber finde ich auf dem iPad auch ziemlich gelungen. Was da überhaupt nicht geht, ist der Kaufprozess. Also dieses, wie lade ich ein Buch runter und sowas. Du wirst halt im Webbrowser geladen und musst dann irgendwie auf irgendeinen Browser kaufen, quasi über die stinknormale Amazon-Webseite. Und dann ist es total unübersichtlich. Dann hab ich nicht gesehen, wie man eigene Dokumente hochladen kann, weil es wäre cool, wenn man in diese Kindle-Applikation auch irgendwie ein eigenes PDF oder sowas reinpacken könnte, was man dann vernünftig lesen kann. Hab ich keine Möglichkeit zu gefunden. Ansonsten ist es, im Gegensatz zu iBooks, was sehr schick und sehr bunt und sehr buchig ist, total simpel. Man hat einfach nur den Text vor sich und das war's. Durch Antippen mit dem Finger kommt man zur nächsten Seite relativ schnell. Find ich eigentlich einen sehr schönen Reader. Aber man kann leider keine eigenen Bücher reinpacken. Das ist leider ein bisschen nervig, wie ich finde. iBooks entgegen, da kann man ja auch, da kann man sich auch, wie heißen die, ODF Bücher? Da hab ich mir zum Beispiel von Cory Doctorow Little Brother installiert.
Der iPad Find vor dem Herrn?
Genau, auf dem iPad will ich das lesen, ein Buch.
Und schreibst du ihm auch eine Mail, wie schön das war?
Ja, sag ich, das war toll. Und per Anhalter durch die Galaxis hab ich mir selbstverständlich draufgeladen. Ich glaub, auch wenn ich da mit einer Urheberrechtsverletzung gegenbegangen haben sollte, Doug Adams hätte es so gewollt. Ich glaube, das ist der Anhalter.
Du hast einen Anhalter als EPUB? Den Englischen? Komplett? Wie viele Bände?
Also ich hab hier den Hitchhiker's Guide und das Restaurant am Ende des Universums. Und was ist das hier noch? Das sind bisher alle, die ich mir... Aber ich wollte die erstmal wieder mal lesen. Zwei von dreien. Zwei von fünf, ne?
Also es gibt... Da gehen glaube ich die Meinungen sehr weit auseinander, ob man diesen fünften...
Der war ein bisschen scheiße, ne? Wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Naja, ob der überhaupt sozusagen zählt.
Ach so.
So in der Mangelung von Douglas Adams. Eigentlich sind es ja nur vier.
Ja, also ich hab auf jeden Fall die ersten beiden Teile. Hitchhiker's Guide und das ist...
Das ist mal eine gute Idee zum Nachschlagen vor allem. Das ist ja etwas, wo man auch mal wieder gerne zitiert und referenziert und nachschlägt und so. Ja, das stimmt.
Endlich Apfel F im Buch.
Ja.
Das heißt natürlich nicht Apfel F., sondern ist eine Lupe, auf die man drauf tippen muss.
Ich frage mich, ob Apple das auch noch bringt, den Reader auf den Mac zu bringen.
Bisher machen sie ja keine Anstalten in der Richtung, oder?
Ja, aber das wäre nun wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr angemessen.
Ich glaube, machen sie nicht. Das ist das falsche Gerät dafür.
Ich werde gerade korrigieren, es gibt einen 6. Band und das ist der von Ohne Douglas Adams, genau. Das liegt daran, dass ich den 5. immer noch nicht gelesen habe. Einmal ruppert und zurück.
Ja, den habe ich auch noch nicht gelesen, glaube ich.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, das war so ein bisschen nach meiner intensiven Lesezeit. Und dann fiel das ein bisschen hinten unter.
Aber jetzt hast du ein iPad, da kannst du es ja wieder...
Stimmt, jetzt kann ich das alles nachholen und so weiter. Also ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich so wirklich zum Pappleser werde, zum E-Pappleser, zum Buchleser, aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass das iPad enorm einschlägt im Game-Markt. Also das... Wie auf dem iPhone ja auch schon, ne? Ich hab mir auch dieses Real Racing gekauft.
Dieses, das hab ich auch geholt, dieses Rennspiel. Das macht Spaß, oder?
Das ist irre irgendwie. Da ist man so, wie sagt man so schön, immersed. Das ist auch eingetaucht, das ist einfach dieses ganze Gerät, was man dahinterhält, ist halt irgendwie so dein Fenster aus diesem Auto heraus und das rockt einfach.
Und da ist nichts Überflüssiges dran?
Nee.
Da ist nicht so, pass auf, dass die Boxen hinten nicht runterreißt oder sowas?
Nee, noch nicht mal irgendwelche User Interface-Controls, weil du tappst halt irgendwie nur ein bisschen drauf und fährst halt irgendwie wie ein Klopter. Ich meine, das ist halt das Spiel mit dem Auto und ich fand eigentlich das Spiel mit dem Auto, weiß ich nicht.
Im besten Fall zum Mittel.
Letztes Mal, dass ich mich glaube ich für das Spiel mit dem Auto interessiert habe, war auf dem C64 da hieß es Pole Position und seitdem hat es irgendwie für mich nicht so richtig...
Das Auto-Rennspiel kann man gängern, fand ich damals ganz schick.
Ja, also jeder hat da glaube ich so eins, was er toll findet und es gibt auch so Leute, die fahren natürlich auf alles Mögliche ab, aber mich, also insbesondere diese blöden Verfolgungsjagden, wo du dann auch irgendwie Frauen vergewaltigen musst und so weiter, das fand ich irgendwie alles nicht so spannend. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Achso, GTA ist auch super, aber das ist kein Auto-Rennspiel.
Naja, aber da fährst du halt so durch Städte durch und musst immer verfolgt werden oder verfolgen und so weiter.
Frauen vergewaltigen ist amerikanischer Alltag?
Nein, das meint man. Mann, ich weiß gar nicht, muss man da auch Frauen vergewaltigen?
Wahrscheinlich, aber jetzt hab ich schon die Büchse der Pandora's. Auf jeden Fall reißt da die ganze Zeit Leute aus ihren Autos raus. Das ist halt brutal, Bombs über alles rüber und so weiter.
Das ist nicht so unser Ding, ne?
Nee, also meinst du, das ist das auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber so reine, nackte Maschine erleben, das find ich wiederum cool.
Need for Speed musst du spielen.
Ja, das ist doch das, wo du da auch die ganze Zeit von Polizei gejagt wirst und so, ne?
Das ist das, was ich ja noch richtig neidisch...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab ja kein PC.
Wie hieß das Spiel? Das hab ich auf der Xbox... Oh, bis zum Apprechen gespielt.
Aber jetzt könnte man den coolen Übergang zu Steam machen.
Ja, ja, könnte man...
Ja, ja, mit iPad reicht's ja lang. Die erste Stunde ist ja schon rum.
Eine Stunde schon. Was?
Oder? Hab ich jetzt mal so gesagt. Ihr seid ja am Fahren, das ist ja unglaublich.
Naja, ich mein, das ist hier... It's the iPad Man.
Ja, gut, das ist ja jetzt auch alles schon ein Monat alt.
Ein Monat alt. Du hast immer noch keins. Wir strahlen hier in den deutschen Empfangsbereich rein. Da hat man in der Regel noch keins.
Aber die WG hat außer mir hier noch gar keiner.
So sieht's aus. Und auch die WLAN-Variante ist eingeschränkt. Oder ist hier im Chat jemand, der ein iPad hat?
Ich sag jetzt überall hat doch wer ein iPad.
Ja, aber was ich echt krass finde an einem Gerät ist, wie sehr die Leute drauf abfahren. Das ist wirklich ausnahmslos jeder.
Welche Leute jetzt?
Leute, die du triffst.
Ja, sehen will man es ja natürlich.
Ja, aber nicht nur irgendwelche Nerds wollen das sehen. Also ich meine, es war ja schon beim iPhone so ein bisschen so, hey, du hast ein iPhone, ja, zeig mal. Ist ja ganz spannend und so. Aber das ist die Freundin von einem guten Freund von mir, die ist irgendwie Anwältin für Arbeitsrecht oder sowas. Also sie interessiert sich nicht die Bohne für Computer. Die hat das iPhone am Anfang angeguckt, als ob es für einen anderen Planeten wäre. Ich hab die neulich getroffen auf seiner Geburtstagsparty. Und dann kommt sie auf mich und sagt so, Max, du hast doch so ein iPad, oder? Wie ist das so? Dann hab ich ihr gezeigt und dann hatte ich es natürlich dabei. Die ist halb ausgeflippt. Also das ist wirklich Leute, denen du bisher mit Technik...
Meinst du, sie hat bei Frauen wieder mehr Chancen nennt?
Ja, das zum einen, definitiv. Zumindest noch bis zum 28. Mai.
Wie klingt das denn? Endlich mal wieder mehr Chancen. Leute, du musst halt bei deinem Sex-Appear arbeiten.
Man muss ja, um auch Dennis eine Gelegenheit geben, einen Kaufaufgaben für dieses Gerät zu geben.
Auch mal eine Frau zu finden.
Nee, aber es interessieren sich wirklich Leute dafür, die sich normalerweise überhaupt nicht für Technik interessieren.
Meine Erfahrung war ähnlich. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie genauso war. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass alle total ausgeflippt sind.
Aber alle wollen mal gucken.
Nee, was ich am interessantesten fand, alle wussten, was ich da habe.
Das ist auch...
Und da würde ich wirklich sagen...
Das steht ja auch drauf.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das Punkt ist, das liegt nur auf dem Tisch. Ich zieh das nur aus irgendwas raus. Es ist immer die Reaktion sofort da. Ah, ein iPad. Also alle wissen den Namen. Alle wissen, dass das so ist, obwohl es ja auch, was weiß ich, irgendwas sein könnte. Das hat mich schon sehr verwundert. Und das greift wirklich auch in Bereiche ein, in Leute, die... Ich weiß nicht, einen Computer nicht mit dem Arsch angucken.
Im Restaurant? Der Kellner?
Der Kellner, genau, so was.
Der sich dann plötzlich hinter den Tresen anfängt, mit einem Koch darüber zu unterhalten, dass da jemand einen iPad hat. Das ist echt krass.
Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass diese Medienwelle, die da losgetreten wurde Anfang des Jahres, so effizient war, dass das jetzt so DSDS-mäßig bekannt ist. Was ist DSDS?
Ja, klar.
Aber auch so diese Namen von Fernsehmenschen, die kennen ja auch immer alle. Was wir auch immer nicht so drauf haben. Ja, da war ja ein Stefan Raab, oder irgendein Name halt, irgendein Moderator Heini.
Denen alle kennen, außer dir.
Denen alle kennen und ich sitze dann immer so und komm mir so ein bisschen...
Die platziert vor und so...
Und mit dem iPad kann man 40 Jahre mitreden. Das iPad kennen halt auch alle so, wie sie diese Fernsehleute kennen. Also sie wissen einfach, dass es das gibt. Und sie haben es auch so häufig gesehen, aus welchen Quellen auch immer, dass sie das sofort erkennen, wenn man eines auf den Tisch legt. Also das wäre echt erstaunlich. Ich würde das gar nicht werten.
Das ist wirklich auffällig.
Gut, aber Dennis wollte ja über Steam reden.
Stimmt. Ich?
Ja, du hast es gesagt. Du hast gesagt, Steam, da könnte man ja mal drüber reden.
Wie ist denn das? Weiß das eigentlich jemand? Da gibt es ja jetzt also Steam. Wolltest du darüber was erzählen? Was ist das eigentlich? Das ist so was für ein PC. Da haben wir schon drüber geredet, mein Freund. Ich weiß, da hatten wir das schon. Aber da habe ich nicht zugehört.
Es ist eine Distributionsplattform für Spieler.
Diese Valve-Firma, das ist ja die, die Half-Life, Counter-Strike und so gemacht hat. Half-Life 2. Und die haben, glaube ich, früher über diese Steam erst mal so eine Art Game-Netz aufgebaut. Oder so ging es, glaube ich, los.
Genau, so Scores abspeichern, das ganze.
Genau, und dann haben sie irgendwann auch angefangen mit, als sie, glaube ich, die Half-Life Engine haben sie irgendwann neu geschrieben oder so, haben das Source genannt, dann gab es irgendwie Half-Life Source und Counter-Strike Source. Und da haben die auch angefangen, die Spiele drüber zu verkaufen.
Genau, und vor allem erstmal die Aktivierung da drüber zu machen. Genau, und dann eben auch nicht nur ihre eigenen Spiele, sondern mittlerweile ist es eben eine offene Plattform. Also es ist quasi so wie iTunes für Musik.
Okay, ist das das für Spiele.
Genau, und das gibt es halt jetzt auch seit ein paar Tagen auf Mac. Ich muss dir sagen, meine erste Launch Experience war jetzt nicht so toll.
Also ich habe es irgendwie runtergeladen, nachdem sie sagten, dass es jetzt da ist. Ich glaube, es war Freitag oder am 13., nein, Donnerstag, keine Ahnung. Und dann ging aber nichts, war überlastet und trallert. Also ich hatte wirklich nur irgendwie diesen Steam-Software selbst und sonst ging nichts. Dann musste ich warten und warten und warten. Als ich am nächsten Tag aufgestanden bin, war dann irgendwie dieses Portal da. Genau, hat mir auf Arbeit einer gesagt, so jetzt würde es gehen, habe es gleich runtergeladen, kam es auch irgendwie rein. Und dann hatte ich es und dann habe ich abends mal gespielt. Und dann konnte man ein bisschen in den Portal, also es ist jetzt ein bisschen blöd das Spiel zu erklären, aber da sind halt so Portale, durch die man so, wie soll ich das erklären, durch die man in andere Räume gucken kann, weil da das Portal wieder rauskommt, so Ein- und Ausgangsportal. Und das war aber immer nur schwarz, du konntest irgendwie durch diese Dinger nicht durchgucken. Und dann aber gab es gestern wohl irgendwie noch mal ein Update und überhaupt jedes Mal, wenn ich das starte, kommt ein Update. Also so ziemlich wirklich jedes Mal. Und gestern kam irgendwie auch ein Update und seitdem geht es jetzt auch. Und jetzt kann man auch durch diese Portale durchgucken und jetzt ist eigentlich alles prima.
Also ich hab das vorgestern mal ausprobiert, weil ich auch dieses Portal, wie ist denn das eigentlich? Kann ich das jetzt kosten? Ist das eine Demo-Version, die bis zum 24. Mai läuft? Oder haben die jetzt gesagt, bis zum 24. Mai ist das kostenlos Portal?
Ich denke mal, da ist wirklich auch schon älter. Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so das riesen Game und so, dass es wirklich auch kostenlos bleibt danach. Also bis zum 24. Mai runterlebt, was auch für die PC-Version gilt.
Gut, also...
Die Geschichte von diesem Portal, kann ich mal ganz kurz erklären, ist, dass die halt dieses coole Spiel gemacht haben. Ist ja mehr so ein Rätsellösenspiel, wo man sich mit Portalen irgendwie cool bewegen muss. Und man kann Portale mit so einer Waffe dann auch irgendwie selber erstellen, damit man da irgendwie vorwärts kommt.
Und was ist ein Puzzle sozusagen?
Ja, ist ja nicht richtig ein Shooter, ist ja wirklich ein Puzzle. Der Spaß ist aber irgendwie so auf 1-2 Stunden beschränkt und dann kennt man irgendwie alle Tricks, und dann lässt es langsam nach. Deswegen ist es nicht so das riesige Übergame. Deswegen haben sie wahrscheinlich auch das genommen, weil es umsonst nicht mehr viel verdient. Und aber damals, die Half-Life 2 Leute haben das wohl gesehen, fanden das cool als Idee, um das in Half-Life 2 zu integrieren und haben die Programmierer von diesem Portal wohl irgendwie gleich mit aufgesogen. Und deswegen in Half-Life 2 gibt es wohl auch lauter Portal-mäßige Tricks und Rätsel, die man irgendwie lösen muss.
Also ich hab schon sehr viel von diesem Portal gehört, hab immer gehört, dass es ein tolles Spiel sein soll und sprach mich jetzt so auch vom ganzen Spielverhalten her sehr an, so dass ich das dann auch gerne haben wollte, hab mir das runtergeladen, dieses Team installiert. War alles nicht so smooth die Experience, wie man sich das vielleicht gewünscht hätte? Also hier und da waren mal ein paar Haken.
Haken im Sinne von, es ruckelt oder was?
Nee, nicht, dass es ruckelt, sondern einfach so, so dass ich mich regelmäßig fragte, was muss ich jetzt hier eigentlich machen, wo muss ich jetzt hin klicken? Und dann musste ich nochmal auf die Webseite drauf und dann da hin klicken und das nochmal machen und dann konnte ich erst das runterladen. Das war alles nicht total trivial, also es war einfach genug, aber ja. Aber am Ende, nachdem ich dann 5 GB runtergeladen hatte, hatte ich dann dieses Portalspiel drauf und mir das mal angeguckt und bin relativ angetan davon. Kann man machen.
Ja, also ich muss ja sagen... Geht schon wieder nicht? Ja, also was haben sie da angekündigt? Ja, jetzt irgendwie Steam-Native-Mackintosh-Anwendung und wir haben es richtig ein Mackintosh-mäßig gemacht. Dann starte ich dieses Programm. Dann kommt das erstmal wieder so einer komplett eigenen Optik hoch. Okay, da dachte ich mir so, das ist so diese Spielewelt.
Ja, das sind halt Spiele.
Ja, das sind halt so Spiele, aber muss es dann auch gleich wieder so super ineffizient sein? Also, wie sich das alles so bedient, ist es irgendwie lahm gewesen, zumindest auf meinem MacBook. Ich starte jetzt hier gerade mal parallel auf dem iMac, um mal zu gucken, was so der... Wesentlich ist das ja auch nur so ein Web-Browser eigentlich.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist das sogar WebKit. Und warum ist da trotzdem ein WebKit? Verstehe ich auch noch nicht so ganz.
Ja, es geht so, aber... Ich hatte dann irgendwie das Gefühl... Ich kann das ja nicht bestätigen, aber so der erste Button, den ich irgendwie gesehen habe, der kam mir dann doch sehr Carbon-mäßig rüber. Das Ding kommt irgendwie in 32 Bit. Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Ja, warum ist das irgendwie 32 Bit? Wenn das jetzt alles so ganz neu entwickelt ist, dann macht man auch irgendwie gleich 64 Bit. Also ich bin irgendwie so ein bisschen skeptisch. Aber ist ja vielleicht auch egal, weil das ist ja letzten Endes nur, in Anführungsstrichen, nur dieses Runterlade-Programm und das kann man ja vielleicht noch ertragen. Ja, weitere Meinungen habe ich dazu nicht, weil ich habe das jetzt noch nicht spielen können, weil auf meinem MacBook, auf meinem alten Schwarzen, wollte der das Programm gar nicht erst starten.
Bei mir sogar mit der kleinen Grafikkarte, das lief problemlos.
Was heißt die kleine Grafikkarte?
Ich habe doch das MacBook mit zwei Grafikkarten drinne.
Das ist ja schon eine ganz andere Generation. Das alte Intel GMA Kram.
Also mit dieser NVIDIA Tralala, weiß ja teuer was.
Dürfen wir jetzt wieder über das iPad reden? Das war jetzt schon vorbei. Indirekt, wir können ja mal diese ganze Flash-Geschichte nochmal aufgreifen.
Ja, genau.
Mir fällt da eigentlich schon fast nichts mehr zu ein. Aber nachdem wir unsere letzte Sendung gemacht haben, kam Olle Steve mit irgendwie Thoughts on Flash. Da musste ich doch sehr schmunzeln. Da hat er eigentlich im Wesentlichen dasselbe zusammengefasst, was wir hier vorher auch schon besprochen haben. Worum es ihm halt einfach geht. Und ich kann ihm auch nach wie vor nur zustimmen.
Also ich hab nochmal so ein...
Das ist ja genauso.
So einen kleinen Blog-Artikel dazu verfasst. Auf meinem Blog. Und... Weil ich hatte nämlich noch den Gedanken, und zwar die Argumentation, dass es darum ginge, irgendwas auszusperren, oder es ist ein App Store oder so was, die greift ja viel zu Kurs. Das könnte ihm theoretisch ja recht sein. Was meine Befürchtung so ein bisschen ist, ist, dass Apple im Augenblick damit den Entwicklungsaufwand für alternative Plattformen, für Android in die Höhe treibt. Und das auch Will darum keinen Flash haben will auf dem Gerät. Will sagen...
Wie den Aufwand für Android in der Höhe treibt.
Das erkläre ich dir gleich. Im Augenblick ist das iPhone noch das meist... mit Abstand das Gerät mit der höchsten Verbreitung. Und wenn man jetzt... Wenn man eine mobile Anwendung rausbringt, dann muss man auf dem iPhone präsent sein. Führt eigentlich im Augenblick keinen Weg dran vorbei. iPhone ist der Goldstandard, an dem es sich zu richten gilt. Naja, es muss ja nicht nur Geld verdienen sein. Das kann ja auch, können ja durchaus auch... Ich denke jetzt mal gar nicht unbedingt so sehr an wirklich die... Ich bin Software-Entwickler und mach nichts anderes als Software, sondern ich denke mal eher so an... Wir wollen einen neuen Film rausbringen und wollen dafür ein kleines Promospiel machen und hätten das gerne auf... Dann sagen die nicht, wir hätten es gerne auf einem Mobiltelefon mit Touch-Bedienung, sondern wir wollen das auf dem iPhone haben. Und genau das ist der Fall, glaube ich, auch den man perfekt in Flash machen kann, nämlich Promo-Zeug für irgendwas. Also so ein kleines Spiel, wo man mit Minimal-Bedienung, jetzt nix fancy 3D oder sowas, sondern einfach Jump'n'Running und noch irgendwie einen Werbeclip mit rein und klickt das mal hier rasch in Flash zusammen. Und das könnte man hier hervorragend in Flash machen und dann könnte nämlich der Entwickler, die Bude, die das anbietet, sagen, wenn wir das gerade für das iPhone machen, dann können wir hier noch diesen Button klicken und dann kommt das auch noch für Android raus hinten.
Kostet aber nochmal 10.000 Euro.
Nö, brauchst ja nicht 10.000 Euro zu kosten im ersten Linie, sondern es ist sozusagen kostlos dabei. Und schwupp, schon gibt es eine Anwendung für Android mehr. Eigentlich legen sie es nur auf die iPhone-Anwendung an. Also ich glaube im Augenblick ist die iPhone-Plattform die einzige interessante für Studios, für entsprechende Software. Firma XYZ, die einen neuen Film rausbringen will. Die will ein Promo-Spiel machen und das will sie für das iPhone haben.
Ja und was hat das jetzt alles mit Flash zu tun? Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Du könntest den Flash entwickeln, wenn es ginge. Dann hättest du ein Flash-iPhone-Programm entwickelt. Das Studio wäre glücklich. Und die Leute, die das machen könnten, sagen übrigens, wir können hier noch einen zweiten Button anklicken und dann habt ihr noch...
Dass das alles geht, wissen wir aber. Was ist jetzt der Grund, warum es keinen Flash gibt?
Ich glaube das Studio wäre nicht glücklich, weil es wird nicht performen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das jemals jemand anguckt. Darum geht es im Zweifelsfall gar nicht. Nein, tatsächlich...
Da kannst du auch Screenshots machen.
Aber das ist doch nur, was gehen würde, wenn Flash gehen würde. Du wolltest uns jetzt erklären, warum Flash nicht geht.
Genau. Und das kann Apple gut abschneiden, indem sie einfach sagen, nee, kein Flash auf dem iPhone. Also bietet sich Flash als Entwicklungsplattform die Chance gibt es einfach nicht, um mit Flash auf dem iPhone zu entwickeln. Darum fällt hinten keine Android-Version raus. Weil wenn sie jetzt ein iPhone-Promospiel machen wollen, müssen sie das in Objective-C machen. Und wenn sie das dann fertig haben, können sie dann auch überlegen, wie hoch wäre der Entwicklungsaufwand, das Ganze jetzt noch auf Android zu portieren. Und dann hast du tatsächlich fast eine Preisverdoppelung, weil du komplett von Grund auf neu entwickeln musst.
Ich verstehe, was du sagen willst. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich finde das zu kompliziert gedacht. So denkt Apple nicht. Apple denkt überhaupt nicht über andere Plattformen nach. Apple denkt über ihre eigene Plattform nach. Die interessierten die anderen Plattformen überhaupt nicht. Sollen die Leute doch für Android irgendwas machen? Da wird eh nichts bei rauskommen.
Das, das halte ich tatsächlich für zu groß, kurz gegriffen.
Jetzt ist der Moment, wo der Streit langsam losgeht.
Ich wollte jetzt keinen Streit geben, aber ich meine...
Ding, ding, ding, die erste Runde ist eröffnet.
Wir müssen nur erklären, worüber wir reden. Und ich denke, was auch viele Leute, die jetzt bei den letzten Sendern, wir hatten ja da irgendwie auch wirklich einen Wahnsinns-Kommentar-Thread zur letzten Sendung, so, was sie nicht verstanden haben, ist, was ich im Wesentlichen auch hier so wiedergebe, ist, das Ganze interpretiert aus dem Blickwinkel von Apple.
Aus deiner Sicht, weil es dich überhaupt betrifft.
Ja, das ist das, was ich mir so anschaue. Also Apple will keinen Flash auf dem iPhone haben. Ich kann das voll verstehen. Total.
Aus Apples Sicht oder aus deiner Sicht?
Aus Apples Sicht. Und ich bin sogar der Meinung, dass ihre Aussage, das ist gut für Benutzer und in gewisser Hinsicht auch gut für Developer, dass das auch greift. Weil das ist, Flash ist bisher im Mobilbereich ein einziger Fail. Ich meine, zu behaupten, es wäre ja verwerflich von Apple, dass sie keinen Flash auf dem iPhone hatten, da kann man einfach nur sagen, es gibt keinen Flash auf Arm. Dieses Produkt existiert einfach nicht. Seit zwei Jahren kündigt Adobe an, dass sie das dann mal tun wollen. Nur existieren tut es nicht. Es gibt kein Telefon auf diesem ganzen Planeten, was eine funktionierende Flash-Implementierung hat. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe sogar bestimmte Zweifel daran, dass es dies jemals geben wird. Also ich lasse mich auch gerne irgendwann dann, vielleicht irgendwann werden sie es dann vielleicht mal rausgebracht haben und dann stürzt es auch irgendwie nicht am laufenden Meter ab. Und dann sind wahrscheinlich dann auch schon so viele Telefone mit den neuesten Prozessoren verkauft worden, damit die genug Power haben. Bloß zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt ist es gar keine Diskussion. Und Apple verkauft schon seit drei Jahren diese Smartphone-Plattform, auf der man interaktive Games hat, auf der man alle möglichen abgefahrenen Anwendungen hat, die man auch so mit Flash gar nicht programmieren könnte, weil man gar nicht einen Zugriff auf diese Sensorik des iPhones hat. Also von daher stellt sich diese Frage eigentlich auch erst mal überhaupt nicht. Und natürlich gibt es auch gar keinen Antrieb von Apple, sich da an Adobe ranzuklatschen, weil sie würden eben von dem Runtime-Development von Adobe abhängen. Und wenn man sich das Runtime-Development von Flash anschaut, dann ist es einfach so, sie haben es bisher geschafft, zwei Plattformen zu unterstützen, nämlich den Mac und Windows, wovon eine der totale Fail ist, nämlich die Mac-Version. Die ist einfach scheiße.
Es gibt noch eine Lieblingsversion.
Von Flash? Von Apple? Von Adobe? Eine offizielle?
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut die performt.
Die gibt es aber auch nur für Intel, Linux.
Diese beschleunigte Flash-Version, die dieses Acceleration-Framework unterstützt, ist jetzt schon offiziell? War das ein Beta? Was war das?
Da gibt es eine Beta-Version von?
Das ist alles diese sagenumwobene 10.1. Beta, Beta, Beta, Beta.
Ich hab mir die mal runtergeladen, hab die installiert auf meinem MacBook.
Hast du so eine Karte, die diese Grafikunterstützung hat?
Offensichtlich.
Das wird nicht viel bringen, weil es ist erst mal nur auf eine oder zwei Grafikkarten beschränkt. Also bestimmte Nvidia-Modelle, es ist auch auf bestimmte Auflösungen des Videos beschränkt.
Es wird was bringen, aber es ist wichtig. Also es bringt was. Im Augenblick ist das, man sieht da halt so ein weißes Kästchen oben in der Ecke kleben, wenn es unterstützt wird sozusagen. Also wenn das Video, was du gerade siehst, mit Grafikkartenbeschleunigung abgespielt wird. Und es bringt das, dass man in Firefox, wo ich ja gerne mal einen unglaublichen Berg an Taps offen habe, und dadurch Flash-Videos sehr stark geruckelt haben, die ruckeln jetzt nicht mehr so schlimm. Bei der Prozessorauslastung oder sowas, kann ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Unterschied feststellen. Also ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass, also ich sehs nicht, ich seh in der Prozessorauslastung nicht, dass ein HD-YouTube-Video plötzlich, oh mein Gott, ich kann ja nebenbei noch das und das machen.
Ja, aber ich meine, man redet ja auch über verschiedene Sachen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es nur um Videos ginge. Sondern Flash performt ja auch sonst nicht. Also auch wenn du ne Flash-Anwendung hast, die jetzt gar kein Video anzeigt, raubt es trotzdem CPU wie Sau. Selbst wenn die Eile einfach nur rumliegen und nichts tun, das ist, ne, das... fressen sie einfach viel Speicher, sie fressen viel Kram und schützen irgendwann ab.
Das stimmt so nicht ganz. Also ich hab sehr, sehr lange mal eine Flash-Anwendung optimiert und man kann da erstaunlich viel rausholen. Es ist bloß einfach so, das, was dir standardmäßig zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Also wenn du einfach den Weg gehst, den die Entwicklungsumgebung empfiehlt, oder der auch der einfachste Weg ist und der bequemste, dann hast du am Ende mit ziemlicher Sicherheit einen ziemlichen Ressourcenfresser.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass dieselbe Ressourcenfresser halt unter Windows nicht so viel Ressourcen frisst.
Oh, Flash ist auch unter Windows nicht gerade...
Gut, das mag sein, aber es ist im Vergleich...
Das kann durchaus sein, ja.
Schlecht, aber wie auch immer. Ich meine, soll es das irgendwie auf Desktop geben? Ich glaube, dass diese anderen Plattformen sich derzeit mit ihrem Devoten-Unterstützen von Flash keinerlei gefallen tun werden.
Wie gesagt...
Diese Ankündigung, dass bei Android 2.2 dann dieses Flash auch irgendwie laufen soll. Ich meine, wann wird das greifen? Wie viele Telefone wird es geben in diesem Jahr, die mit Android 2.2 laufen? Eine Handvoll wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich habe auch mal diese Nexus-1s verändert und abgedatet, sehr, sehr schnell.
Die, die sie jetzt nicht mehr verkaufen.
Die sie im Augenblick gerade nicht mehr über die Webseite verkaufen.
Und auch nicht über Reisen anbieten werden, wie sie vorher gesagt haben und so.
Ja, das scheint nicht so richtig gut.
Diese Android-Plattform hat einfach derzeit sehr viele Probleme. Insbesondere was diese Sache der Software-Konsistenz betrifft. Es gibt unterschiedliche User-Interfaces. Gut, das kann man irgendwie sehen. Aber wir sehen, wie weit Linux damit gekommen ist mit solchen Auseinandersetzungen. Sie haben das Problem, dass es einfach keinen garantierten Software-Update gibt. Weil in dem Moment, wo das in der Hand der Telefonhersteller ist, die haben kein großes Interesse daran, ewig Software-Support zu machen.
Da muss Google definitiv ran. Das ist ein Problem, muss ich sagen.
Das ist das Hauptproblem. Was war die Zahl irgendwie? 75% aller Android-Telefone sind nicht aktuell.
Sie sind nicht nur nicht aktuell, sondern sind ein, sechs oder älter.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Flash, worum es mir geht. Was hilft es bitte Android, Flash zu unterstützen? Was hilft es bitte RIM, Blackberry OS, was hilft es, den Flash zu unterstützen? Die holen sich doch den Belseboob ins Haus. Das ist doch für die der totale Fail, wenn sie sich Flash mit reinholen und Adobes Vision der Plattform Adobe R. Das ist doch auch ein Grund, warum Apple dagegen ist. Das ist für die keine Hilfe. Android hat auch ein Development-Modell, das ist ja auch so blöd nicht. So wie Android ebenso funktioniert und wie die Programme ineinander greifen und sich da irgendwie gegenseitig die Events vorballern und ihr Konzept von Background-Applications, das wird mit Flash nicht gehen. So, sondern Flash wird einfach nur so ein paar olle Games bringen, die halt nicht performen und dann irgendwann abstürzen. Was soll das für eine Experience sein? Was hat die Android-Welt davon? Was hat diese begeisterte... Also ich sehe ja auch und verstehe ja auch, dass es da einen bestimmten Developer-Kreis gibt, der von Android sehr viel mehr angetan ist, als von der iPhone-Welt. Der ist zahlenmäßig noch gering, aber den gibt es zumindest. Was haben die davon, wenn Flash unterstützt wird? Da haben die nichts von.
Also Flash im Browser bin ich total bei dir. Und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob das jetzt so dieses... Ich finde auch nicht, dass Apple jetzt zwingend irgendwie auf Adobe zugehen müsste und sagen, hey, was müssen wir denn tun, damit Flash vernünftig läuft auf dem iPhone? Warten. Das finde ich auch nicht. Also Adobe hat jetzt kein Recht, da irgendwie in diesen Browser rein zu dürfen. Das finde ich, bin ich total bei dir. Ich finde allerdings diesen anderen Fall, wenn sie, also das sozusagen Flash im Webbrowser. Jetzt gibt es ja aber dieses Flash als Standalone, was Standalone-Apps produziert fürs iPhone. So, die sich sozusagen als, die über den ganz regulären App-Store-Weg auf das Gerät kommen und die dann dieser stinknormalen Evolution sozusagen, oder Auswahl unterworfen sind. Und den, finde ich, sollte man keine Steine in den Weg legen. Also und das haben sie getan, durch diese Änderung in der entsprechenden Passage, durch dieses Agreement.
Ich verstehe nicht, Apple sollte Wiem keine Steine in den Weg legen?
Also Adobe hat Flash so erweitert, dass sie sagen, hey, wir können damit echte, native iPhone-Applikation entwickeln.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Das ist doch CS5. Flash CS5 kann Programme rauslassen.
Kann ein Binary erzeugen, was ein Flash in seiner Flash-Welt im iPhone OS abspielt. Aber native iPhone-Programme ist was anderes. Das ist kein natives iPhone-Programm. Weil das nicht nativ gegen das API von dem iPhone OS programmiert ist. Es fühlt sich eben nicht so an.
Das weißt du ja nicht, weil du keins hast.
Weil ich was nicht hab.
Du hast ja so ein Programm nicht.
Doch, es gab ja mal diese paar Flash-Apps, die da irgendwie schon durchgerauscht sind.
Hast du die runtergeladen und mal ausprobiert? Also ich nicht.
Das sind halt so komische Games, die so funktionieren.
Wie so tausende komische Games im App-Store sind.
Ne, eben nicht. Die kommen nicht iPhone, Nest hoch. Die haben nicht Settings und Screens und Standard-User-Interface-Controls und irgendwie On-Off-Buttons, wie das bei anderen Programmen ist. Sondern das ist einfach nur so Flash. Das ist einfach nur so Grafik mit Grafik-Buttons, die sich alle überhaupt nicht so verhalten, wie man das möchte.
Wie das dritte iPhone-Spiel.
Ne, das ist nicht so wie das dritte iPhone-Spiel.
Ich hab die meisten... Oder auf dem iPad dieses Real Racing 3D.
Wir kommen da nicht weiter. Auf jeden Fall, ich verstehe Apple da vollständig. Ich sehe Probleme.
Die schützen halt ihr Revier, ist da ganz einfach.
Sie schützen ihr Revier, ja, genau. Ich find's ja auch...
Ja, sie wollen sich da ihre Zukunft sichern. Und was können sie besseres tun, als fremde APIs weghalten? Ich find das noch immer. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja nun auch sehr interessant zu sehen, was diese Videodiskussion betrifft, dass es da ja nun sehr wohl interessante Wege gibt. Also, dass viele, die sich groß beklagt haben, dass man ja ohne Flash nicht könnte, auf einmal problemlos auch zeigen, dass sie das ohne Flash sehr wohl auch können, Video-deliveren. U-Porn. Also, so wäre der Spiegel, hat ja einen Quick-Fix eingebaut.
Ja, das ist alles noch nicht so richtig schön.
Das ist nicht schön. Sie linken einfach nur direkt auf ihre MP4-Videos so, aber das kostet sie ja jetzt nicht so sehr viel, da quasi auch noch einen HTML5-Rahmen drum herum zu bauen. Dann haben sie im Prinzip genau die gleiche Experienz.
Aber die Werbung können sie jetzt nicht mehr einblenden. Vorher hatten sie wahrscheinlich schöne Movieplayer in Flash, die immer schön Werbung einblenden und schnick schnack.
Wieso können sie jetzt die Werbung nicht mehr einblenden? Sie können genau dasselbe einblenden, wie sie jetzt auch einblenden können. Sie machen es halt nicht mit Flash, sondern mit JavaScript und HTML5.
Das wird schon kommen.
Sie müssen es halt machen.
Ich finde es, das finde ich tatsächlich jetzt mal wieder rein praxisrelevant im RSS-Reader, in den Newswire nutze ich da im Augenblick für, wie weit man doch kommt. Also es gibt kaum, also erstaunlich viel liegt offensichtlich als YouTube-Video vor. Wie Meo-Videos funktionieren auch.
Zunehmend.
Zunehmend. Allerdings nie direkt in der Seite, sondern man muss dann immer darauf hoffen, dass die Person dann nochmal so einen Direktlink eingebaut hat, was ich ja eine Zeit lang...
Ja, das ist noch das Problem mit diesem Embedding.
Genau.
Wenn das Embedding halt direkt sagt, hier Flash, dann ist es halt Flash.
Da muss halt neues Embedding rein und dann geht das auch alles. Es ist noch nicht alles perfekt ohne Flash. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sich jedes Video, was da draußen angeht, angucken kann, aber es ist erstaunlich viel. Es ist jetzt so in meinem Feed-Reader. Also ich nutze zum Beispiel hier das Fail-Blog, gucke ich mir ganz gerne mal an. Die haben einen eigenen Player, haben aber immer noch meistens einen Link auf YouTube oder eben auf Vimeo. Das geht dann immer. Also man muss da im Zweifelsfall im Augenblick noch ein bisschen mehr klicken oder ein bisschen mehr tippen, aber das geht. Erstaunlich gut. Nicht mehr so rasend viel. Ich habe ja die Themenliste. Ich sitze ja tatsächlich als Einziger von uns komplett ohne Mac da im Augenblick, sondern wirklich nur mit dem iPad. Und Google Wave läuft ja noch nicht auf dem iPad. Darum kann ich nicht nachgucken. Dass du es mal als Argument sehen würdest, dass Google Wave irgendwo drauf nicht läuft.
Ja, also im Chat sehen es natürlich wieder ein paar anders irgendwie. Ich muss auch sagen, ich finde ihr versteht das nicht so richtig. Hier, es ist nicht Flash, es ist R. R ist Flash. Da ist zwar viel JavaScript und HTML-Gedöns auch noch mit dabei, aber am Ende geht es hier um einen klaren Krieg. Und das ist halt der Krieg der Entwicklungsplattformen. Adobe ist halt seit längerer Zeit auf dem Weg, auch Anwendungsentwickler an sich binden zu wollen durch dieses R. Wie sollten sie es denn sonst alles rausbringen? Das bringt ja sie unmittelbar so kein Geld, außer dass sie halt CS irgendwas verkaufen. Und sie wollen halt da eine alternative Plattform machen und quasi einen New RP rausbringen, so wie das Microsoft probiert hat mit.NET, so wie es Apple probiert hat mit ihrem Objective-C. Das ist halt sozusagen so ein Framework War. Java kommt da noch mit rein. Und an der Stelle sind die sich natürlich alle nicht grün, und da will natürlich jeder möglichst viele Developer auf seine Seite ziehen. So ist das. Ja, so ist das. Hier kommt halt wieder das Argument, mit Developer sollen ihre Waffen selbst wählen dürfen. Klar.
Apple wählt seine Waffen auch selbst.
Ja, ebenso. Das ist halt der Punkt. Apple tut halt erstmal das, was gut für Apple ist.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, damit muss ich ja nicht einverstanden sein.
Ist Flash halt nicht.
Also, und die Perspektive Apples ist mir da relativ wurscht.
Also ich persönlich, ehrlich gesagt...
Also stell dir fest, Max ist damit nicht einverstanden, Tim ist voll auf der Seite von Apple, mir ist eigentlich total schnozend. Ich will jetzt das Thema wechseln, verdammte Scheiße. Ja, du hast doch die Liste da.
Ja, aber wenn du ein anderes Thema haben willst, dann musst du auch schon ein Thema am Start haben. Also was ich mir ja noch notiert habe, was vielleicht noch diskussionswürdig wäre, was jetzt einen komplett anderen Weg nimmt, das ist das neue Release von McRuby, wo wir ja hier schon mal ein bisschen länger darüber geredet haben.
Ja, aber da haben wir ja hier unseren Experten nicht am Start.
Ja, das stimmt. Schon wieder im Urlaub? Ist er jetzt auch mit dem Motorrad unterwegs oder was?
Nee, das war nur so gesagt, weil er nicht da ist.
Ich weiß es ja nicht.
Ich bin ab morgen im Urlaub, das heißt in zwei Wochen können wir keine Sendung machen.
Ja.
Vielleicht ganz knapp, ihr könnt ja eine planen und dann gucken wir mal. Nach zwei Wochen.
Naja, also in unseren zwei Wochen kriegen wir uns schon länger nicht mehr hin. Wir sind schon eher eine Drei-Wochen-Sendung. So ist es. Na gut, McRuby ist halt rausgekommen. Soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, ist das das erste Release, von dem sie sagen, jetzt könnte man halt auch richtige Cocoa-Anwendungen machen. So viel zum Thema mit, woran Apple alles so arbeitet, womit man so entwickeln kann. Also ich bin nur noch der Meinung, dass Ruby da durchaus eine Chance hat, wenn sie nicht irgendwann nochmal abgesägt werden, aufzusteigen in denselben Level wie Objective-C. Das wäre toll.
Was ist die weltbeste Programmiersprache? Insgesamt. Die weltbeste Programmiersprache.
Ich sag's euch, Subjective-C.
Aber nochmal zu Flash, weil jetzt fielen wir zu Flash auch nochmal rein. Da gab's doch die Gerüchte, das habt ihr ja ausgelassen. Die neuesten News, da gibt's ja dieses Gerücht, dass Apple da an so einer Art eigenem Flash arbeitet. Ich hab jetzt diesen komischen Namen da vergessen. Da war doch was.
Habt ihr nämlich ganz ausgelassen.
Weil ihr streitet euch ja lieber. Die neuesten, modernen Techniken.
Das hat sich doch sowieso schon als Fake.
Nein, nein, das ist kein Fake. Was wolltest du sagen?
Als Gerücht, als nicht wahres Gerücht erwiesen.
Was?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es hieß. Wie hieß denn das Toolkit?
Ich guck mal nach. Obwohl, wenn man jetzt nach Apple und Flash schaut, findet man alles nur nicht das.
Naja, ich meine, es ist ja überhaupt keine Neuigkeit.
Geandui. Ich meine, da haben wir es doch komisch. Das kann man sich ja gar nicht einfallen lassen, oder?
Nee, das gibt es. Das bezweifle ich ja gar nicht.
Es gibt ja nicht nur ein Framework, sondern es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Frameworks. Und das finde ich ja auch so schön, dass man jetzt, wenn alles auf Webkit bzw. alles auf JavaScript oder auf HTML5 basiert, dass es eben jetzt einen freien Wettbewerb von verschiedenen Frameworks gibt, von denen meiner Meinung nach Flash nur eins ist. Adobe wird sich langfristig nur damit retten können, dass sie Flash auf HTML5-Basis neu rausbringen. Da werden sie irgendwie ein paar Features cutten müssen und es wird vielleicht ein Subset sein, weil da ihr DIM nicht mit dabei ist etc.
Wir sind es ja schon dran.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie da wirklich so richtig dran sind. Ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass sie wirklich dran sind. Wenn sie dran sein wollten, dann sind sie dran.
Bei der Flash CS5, also bei der neuesten Version, wurde viel gefeiert, gibt es eine Möglichkeit, einfache Flash-Banner, auch als HTML5, kann was zu exportieren.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist dann erst mal nur die kleine Animation, ausreichend für wahrscheinlich einen Werbebanner?
Genau, das ist halt irgendwie beschränkt. Sie können diese Beschränkung weiter aufnehmen. Dann kannst du irgendwie adobe.com/script/flash.js nachladen und dann hast du halt irgendwie deinen Flash in welchem modernen Browser auch immer. Und so muss das eigentlich auch sein. Und genauso gibt es eben verschiedene andere Frameworks. Ähnlich ist es ja auch mit Silverlight und so weiter. Das sind ja auch alles diese Versuche, da nochmal was proprietäres hineinzustoßen. Und ich finde halt einfach, an der Stelle hat auch Apple, also ist es nicht nur so, dass ich jetzt Apples Move im Hinblick auf ihren eigenen Vorteil, ihr eigenes Interesse verstehen kann, sondern dass ich an der Stelle sie sogar extrem unterstütze, weil sie sind derzeit die Einzigen, die wirklich aktiv was tun dafür, dass das Web einfach mal wieder das Web führt. Und nicht irgendein proprietäres Plugin, was installiert werden muss, damit du dir Inhalte auf Webseiten anschauen kannst. Wo leben wir denn? Das geht nicht. Was haben wir gekotzt bei Java Applets? Was haben wir gekotzt bei ActiveX? Da ist Flash in dem Sinne auch nichts anderes. Das hat einfach zu verschwinden. Webseiten haben einfach Webseiten zu sein und ausschließlich auf Basis von der W3C abgesegneten Webstandard zu funktionieren. Wie gesagt, ich habe keine Sekunde lang ging durch, wenn es um Webbrowser geht. Müssen wir ja auch gar nicht. Das ist auch das, worum es mir im Wesentlichen geht. Das Web, also die Applikation ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte, aber beim Web hat einfach dieses Flash mittelfristig, wenn nicht sogar kurzfristig, zu verschwinden. Ich sehe sehr viel mehr Wert darin, dass eben diese neuen Frameworks hochkommen, deren es ja so einige gibt. Ich kann auch gerne nochmal auf die JavaScript-Sendungen verweisen, die ich gemacht habe bei Chaos Radio Express. Vor ein paar Tagen kam ja übrigens hier GitHub, nicht wahr? Kennt ihr ja sicherlich. Da gibt es jetzt so eine Webseite, die heißt GitHub-Issues, wo sozusagen nur noch der Issue-Tracker von GitHub drauf abgebildet ist. Und das haben die Leute gemacht von diesem, wie hieß es gleich noch, 360 Grad, 270 irgendwas. Ich bringe es hier einfach mal auf, dann weiß ich. Und zwar haben die das in diesem Cappuccino-Framework neu gemacht mit Objective-J sozusagen. So wie Objective-C sich zu C verhält, verhält sich Objective-J zu JavaScript. Aber basiert eben komplett auf JavaScript runtime engine. Und dieses GitHub-Issues, was heißt denn das? Ich hab's noch nicht ganz genau getroffen. Nicht issues.com, sondern doch GitHub-Issues, achso, Punkt heroku.com githubissues.heroku.com Und da kannst du dich dann mit deinem GitHub- api-key einloggen, den du hast, wenn du einen Account hast. Und dann kriegst du halt so ein Interface, was so richtig voll modern ist und sich richtig wie so eine Applikation bedient. Ja, ich muss mal gucken, wie weit ich jetzt hier komme ohne... Genau, 280 North heißen die. Ich verwechsel das immer mit Folder.
Die haben auch diese Keynote-Alternative schon geschrieben.
Guck mal hier, so sieht das jetzt hier aus. Also so ein richtiger typischer Multi-Pain-Browser. So ähnlich wie iTunes, sag ich mal. Wo du halt hier wirklich schick formatiert diese ganzen Kommentare und die Issues von GitHub. Also wenn du halt jetzt auf GitHub developst und dann auf irgendein öffentliches Repository gehst. Oder eben wenn du angemeldet bist, eben auch auf die geschlossenen Repositories, siehst du halt hier die Issues und so weiter. Dann kannst du richtig schön mit Körsertasten durchgehen und so. Und es ist total schick und total schnell und total nett. Und das denke ich, ist einfach die Zukunft. Wir werden jetzt einfach ein sehr lebendiges Web sehen, wo verschiedene JavaScript-Frameworks miteinander konkurrieren. Und wo wir einfach in zwei, drei Jahren reden wir einfach nicht mehr über Flash.
Mal gucken, was Apple macht, wenn dann die ersten Pages und Numbers-Ersatz im Web kommt. Ob die es dann immer noch toll finden.
Gibt's schon. Gerade von diesen Tuan und Eti North, die haben ja so einen Keynote-Klon geschrieben.
Ich hab da ein bisschen in den Überblick verloren. Da gab's dieses Cappuccino Toolkit, was so Objective J war das.
Genau, 280 Slides heißt das Ding hier. Also das sind dieselben Leute, 280slides.com. Guck mal, es sieht genauso aus wie Keynote. Und findet halt vollständig im Web statt.
Hast du dir mal Gmail auf dem iPad angeguckt? Das ist auch eine Applikation, die von Tag zu Tag besser wird.
Ja, und da findet halt diese Konkurrenz statt. Also dieses Flash ist einfach ewig gestrich. Das ist einfach nicht die Zukunft, Leute.
Wie gesagt, wir reden nicht von Flash im Webbrowser. Und es geht mir auch gar nicht so sehr im Flash, sondern es geht mir alternativer Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, guck mal, Dennis. Sieht doch genauso aus wie Keynote. Exakt dasselbe User-Interface hier. Sieht irgendwie sogar mit da oben mit der Toolbar-Leiste und so weiter. Ist alles voll geklont. Was sagt Apple dazu? Gar nichts. Was sollten sie dazu auch sagen?
Könnten sie auch immer sagen, finden wir Scheiße. Die machen ja unsere Programme platt mit freier Software.
Ich denke, Apple weiß schon, dass sie einfach auch weiterhin immer versuchen müssen, alle zwei, drei Jahre voraus zu sein. Und der Tag, an dem ihnen das nicht mehr gelingt, da werden sie dann auch eingeholt werden vom Mainstream. Und das wissen sie, dass sie dann auch gefressen werden.
Ich würde jetzt gerne dem Ende entgegenschreiten.
Dem Ende? Gucken wir mal, ob sich hier noch jemand was wünscht. Wünscht ihr sich was? Ja, der Chat redet gerade über Facebook, aber damit fangen wir jetzt nicht an.
Nein.
Auf keinen Fall. Tja, Porno schreiben sie. Na ja, hatten wir schon. Porno und Weltfrieden. Okay, Dennis, willst du noch irgendwas sagen oder bist du jetzt nur frustriert, dass wir uns die ganze Zeit über...
Nö, war ja schon okay.
Du musst ja mal was für deine Fans tun.
Wir haben nur Flash und iPad gemacht heute.
Du hast zu viele Fans. Was? Wir haben uns ja auch vorbereitet. Wir haben hier Geräte mitgebracht.
Extra gekauft.
Ich hab mein Flash auch mitgebracht. Hier klickst du Flash.
Die Geräte müssen wir übrigens alle anteilig bezahlen. Das ist ja hier quasi Mobile-Max-Podcast-Kauf. Das heißt, du überweist mir noch 200 Euro.
Ich schick dir dann den Rechner von dem MacBook Pro. Ja, ne ich hab auch nichts.
Gut.
Außer das ist die Beta 3 von OS 4. Hab ich das gesagt?
Wasch, das hast du gerade gesagt.
Also diese Beta 3 von XX, die ist nicht schlecht.
Von diesem Mobiltelefonbetriebssystem.
Das hab ich nicht gesagt.
Hat eigentlich schon jemand Android auf einem alten iPhone installiert von euch?
Stimmt, da gab es auch irgendwas, ne?
Ja, das ist...
Macht doch voll Sinn. Wir sollten lieber mal das iPhone US auf so einem Android-Telefon denksten. Dann wär das zu sagen, ein Hacken-Phone.
Das wird bestimmt auch noch kommen. Okay, wir züngern das Elend nicht sinnlos hinaus, sondern wir machen hier einfach einen Punkt und sagen Tschüss.
Winke, Winke.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und bis bald, keine Ahnung wann das sein wird, vielleicht in zwei Wochen, vielleicht auch nicht.
Irgendwann im Juni frühestens. Mit mir zumindest.
Okay, das war's.